this is jaco podcast number 300 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening and also
joining us tonight dave burke good
evening dave good evening
the secretary of the navy takes pleasure
in transmitting
to first lieutenant schmedley darlington
butler united states marine corps the
brevet medal which is awarded in
accordance with marine corps order
number 26 for distinguished conduct and
public service in the presence of the
enemy
while serving with second battalion of
marines
near chen sin
china on 13 july 1900
on 28 march 1901 first lieutenant butler
is appointed captain by brevet
to take rank from 13 july 1900
awarded for actions war department
general orders number 177
december 4th 1915 the president of the
united states of america in the name of
congress takes pleasure in presenting
the medal of honor
to major smedley darlington butler
united states marine corps
for distinguished conduct in battle
in the engagement of veracruz mexico on
22 april 1914.
major butler was eminent and conspicuous
in command of his battalion he exhibited
courage and skill in leading his men
through the action of the 22nd and in
the final occupation of the city
awarded for action
the president of the united states of
america in the name of congress takes
pleasure in presenting the medal of
honor second award
to major smedley darlington butler
united states marine corps
for extraordinary heroism
in action as commanding officer of
detachments from the 5th 13th 23rd
companies and the marine and sailor
detachment from the uss
connecticut major butler led the attack
on fort riviere haiti on 17 november
1915.
following a concentrated drive several
different detachments of marines
gradually closed in on an old french
bastion fort in an effort to cut off all
avenues of retreat for the caico bandits
reaching the fort on the southern side
where there was a small opening in the
wall major butler gave the signal to
attack and marines from the 15th company
poured through the breach engaged the
caicos in hand-to-hand combat took the
bastion
and crushed the caico resistance
throughout this perilous action
major butler was conspicuous for his
bravery and forceful leadership
so there you go
major schmedley butler
uh united states marine for 34 years
fought in the philippines china central
america fought in the caribbean during
the banana wars fought in world war one
although against his wishes he was
more in a support role
he's one of only 19 men in history to
receive two medals of honor
he's one of only three men to receive
the marine corps brave
medal and the medal of honor
and he's the only man in history to
receive two medals of honor and the
brave medal
and
with that career
after he retired from the marine corps
he wrote a book called war is a racket
you heard that right war is a racket
this is a book
that harshly condemns war
denounces the military industrial plo
complex vilifies the captains of
industry and politicians along the way
and disparages americans america's
foreign actions in war
so there's a bit of an about face going
on
and these are some extreme views
that he has
and
when individuals make extreme statements
sometimes that's not the best approach
to take
because
sometimes extreme statements
though they're they may be true or parts
of them may be true
it can also alienate
the general populace and and
kind of
kind of lead people to throw the baby
out with the bathwater on some stuff
meaning that
they throw away someone's ideas they
throw away all of someone's ideas
because some of the ideas that the
person has or the way that they state
them is in an extreme manner
which is i personally don't think it's a
good idea well it's a good it's a good
thing to understand it's a good thing to
understand because what that should tell
you is that if you
if you back off the extremity of your
statements a little bit you're gonna get
more people to listen to them so that's
a good thing to understand
and it's also a good thing to understand
that if people are talking in a really
extreme way you shouldn't just say you
know what this person's just crazy i'm
not gonna listen to him maybe you should
actually listen to what they try and say
and decipher what's just extreme and
maybe not true but are there kernels of
truth in what people are saying
so i think it's a smart idea for us to
listen
and i think
as we have watched america's
withdrawal from afghanistan
in the late summer of 2021 after 20
years of war after thousands of lives
after trillions of dollars
and no progress
maybe we should
at least listen to what this marine
major general
smedley butler
one of the most decorated marines that
ever lived
maybe we should listen to some of what
he has to say
and see if there's some things in there
that make some sense
we have to get a little basic
understanding of smedley butler who he
was where he came from
um
born july 30th 1881
eldest of three sons father was a lawyer
and a junk and a judge he came from a
good background
his grandfather was a congressman
and his and his father was connected
he was a connected guy
and smedly butler went to
an exclusive private school which is
sort of an east coast thing i mean i
guess they have them out on the west
coast but on the east coast is a bigger
thing to have exclusive private schools
he went to one called the haverford
school
and so you kind of get this image you
know you kind of get this image okay
well you know he's
this rich kid that went to this
exclusive school
and then you hear that he left school 38
days before his 17th birthday to enlist
in the marine corps
which is
i think we have to give him credit right
we just have to say credit that's pretty
much what you say credit
he still got his diploma they allowed
him to graduate he
lied about his age
and gets commissioned to second
lieutenant so i don't know how he pulled
that off
but this is back in the day man there's
no records you're just showing up how
old are you 23 i went to college
whatever people like oh okay
you know what i'm saying this is back in
the day there's no isn't it the kind
where like your id card is written in
yeah like by hand yeah you like change
that one to a seven yeah you're good
yeah or you're just you're really just
making adjustments yeah yeah
so i feel like i missed out on a lot of
stuff in life because i didn't have that
kind of yeah i mean we were close you
know but we were just they were still
tracking stuff
so he's 16 years old and he leaves his
high school to go and join the marine
corps shows up gets a commission as a
second lieutenant and he's the spanish
american war is going down but he gets
there a little late um
ends up showing up in gitmo after it's
been invaded after it's been captured
doesn't really see any combat
gets assigned to the
to the philippine american war
he shows up there
he's bored at first
gets in trouble gets temporarily
temporarily relieved of command because
he's drunk and doing whatever
gets his job back however
um october 1899 he gets his first combat
action
leads 300 marines in to take the town of
novaletta one marines killed ten or
wounded his first sergeant's company
first sergeants wounded
there's a little note about him like
panicking at first a little bit and then
he kind of gets composure
ends up in the boxer rebellion
so battle of qin sin this is in china
he
he definitely kind of shows up now
there's a wounded marine officer and he
is in the trench
um smedley butler's in a trench and he
exposes himself to enemy fire
to rescue this marine he ends up getting
shot in the thigh
his commanding officer major waller who
later became the best man at his wedding
he commended him and wrote for such
reward as you may deem proper for the
following officers lieutenant smedly d
butler for the admirable control of his
men in all the fights of the week
and for saving a wounded man at the risk
of his own life under very severe fire
and that's what got turned into the
brevet promotion
which
which the brivette um if my memory
serves me correctly the marine corps had
it for like maybe 20 years and it
basically was you're getting promoted it
was a promotion so that's why even when
i read it says oh he went from from from
first lieutenant to captain it was a
promotion and then they
people that got promoted that way they
eventually got an award
called the brevet medal
which looks like the ribbon of a medal
of honor you know the medal of honor has
the white it's it's a light blue the
brevet with the light blue with stars
the brivette is red
with stars but it looks very similar as
far as the ribbon goes
so he gets that promotion he ends up in
the banana wars
these are
police actions
and
these are police actions that we're
conducting to maintain you know trade
and
and the way we want things to be in the
way america wants things to be in
central america and in the caribbean
honduras rolls into honduras he gets
tasked with defending the us consulate
during a revolt there
he rescues the consulate in trujillo he
gets this nickname his nickname is old
gimlet eye
gimlet is a is a hand drill it's
something that it's a two it's an old
school two that used to drill wood so he
had this piercing look that he would
give people and they called him old
gimladi
uh broken service gets out gets married
has kids runs a coal mine in west
virginia goes back in the marine corps
it must have been easy to get out in and
out of the marine corps back then he
does it a couple times
more fighting in central america
battalion commander
in um in nicaragua
fought in the battle of mazaya
leads the assault the bombardment the
assault and the capture of coyote hill
next up is veracruz these guys are he's
rolling i mean they're doing they're
they're getting it on
with these
low intensity conflicts i remember one
of my old senior chiefs said what we
need is a low-intensity conflict in a
high per diem area
which i always got a kick out of
so that's what he's got going on these
guys are in low intensity conflict
hyperedim area mexico veracruz first
medal of honor so they end up going
through veracruz they're kind of
clearing it door-to-door
there's 5
800 sailors and marines on this
operation
17 killed in action 63 wounded in action
which
if you think about that's 5 800 sailors
and marines there's 17 killed this is so
the the fighting i'm trying to say that
the fighting wasn't that extreme
but there was medals of honor given out
pretty
pretty um
uh a lot so one army guy got a medal of
honor nine marines got a medal of honor
and 46 navy sailors got the medal of
honor
from this action at veracruz so
he eventually tried to return the medal
and said hey i didn't do anything to
earn this and they not only did they
tell him to keep it they told him you
better wear it too so
that's his first medal of honor he
didn't feel comfortable about it um but
he got it haiti second medal of honor
fighting the haitian the caicos rebels
the rebel group down there
and they have this stronghold he kind of
heard me talk about it in the in the
citation there
but he's getting the medal of honor the
the whole battle was 20 minutes long
this assault there was one marine
wounded
and he was wounded by being hit with a
rock
in the face
all 51 of the rebels were killed
so
he got the medal of honor for that
and that's what happened
after that he became like a public
administrator or sort of sort of a
military
i don't know many dictator kind of
running things a little bit the public
works and keeping things you know the
social order and he also it's also said
that they hunted the remaining
rebels like pigs
[Applause]
world war one comes around
he requests
he wants to go into combat again um he
had a reputation of being brave he had a
reputation of being smart he also had a
reputation of being a little bit of uh
a little bit of a rebel a little bit
unreliable
and
and so
i don't know if that's why they decided
not to put him in combat because i'm
thinking if world war one they would be
like oh yeah you're just the guy we're
looking for
you're brave and you're smart but you're
super crazy come on up to the front
lines we got something for you but they
didn't he ended up running this
debarkation depot
you know in the rear
and the by all accounts he did a great
job
and squared this thing away was a real
mess when he showed up and he squared it
away
and he got the army in the navy
distinguished service medal
um
after that he goes and he's the
commanding general of quantico
when he was the commanding this guy was
always doing something he's one of those
people like he always was doing
something when he was the commanding
general at quantico
they used to form up the troops and they
would march to various battlefields
civil war battlefields
and do reenactments and he would lead
the marches
so
yeah i mean he's just they they march
from quantico to damn gettysburg right
and he was in front leading it and they
got up there
let's do let's do the walk of gettysburg
so so then he's so he gets done with
that now he has a broken service
and he becomes the philadelphia director
of public safety and and this is like i
might need a movie reference here echo
charles yes sir uh
what's a movie where they're like
gangsters they're trying to crack down
untouchables
sure okay
he so there's there's this is the time
there's speakeasies and the prohibition
is going on and he comes like law dog
right he is go he comes into he has a
personal war on crime for two years and
it seems like
when you read about it seems like it's
its own movie right this guy is going in
just
ready to take things on he will he
wasn't allowed to fire
if i remember this correctly he wasn't
allowed he found out he wasn't allowed
to fire individual police because the
union and whatever so what he did was he
would just take and just move them all
around all the time so they didn't have
they didn't have time to get to get to
know the local criminals and get paid
off so he just moved him all the time
they were moving that's like one of the
things that he did
and he he made a lot of enemies because
of so many people are corrupt
made a bunch of enemies finally he gets
kind a little bit he did it does it for
two years
he cleans up a lot of stuff
but also makes a bunch of enemies his
final shot in the papers before he went
back in the marine corps
he said cleaning up philadelphia was
worse than any battle i was ever in
uh when he comes back in he's comes
comes the base commander in san diego
deployed with the marine expeditionary
force to china does a good job there
politically
influences a bunch of people
makes major general at 48 years old
and in that time also his dad died and
his dad was super influential
he was like i said he was always kind of
he always kind of had a spotlight put on
him and one of the things when
mussolini's now in power he and there
was some weird um
like a conspiracy about mussolini in a
hit and run or something like this
i forget
but he sort of spread those rumors
you know i think if he had twitter he
would have been a real popular twitter
dude because he started spreading this
guy you know this guy is a murderer and
and the italian government this was
before the war the italian government
was like hey get get your bully in check
and they pressured the sec nav to to
court-martial butler and they did they
court-martialed butler i think he was
the highest ranking
military person to be arrested
after the civil war so he got arrested
and he apologized they let him off of
the reprimand
um the commandant of the marine corps
died at the time and he was kind of in
the running
and he ends up it's pretty obvious that
he's a he's not
enough of a company guy
to get commandant and he doesn't get it
so he retires from the marine corps
october 1st 1931
he starts going on like a lecture tour
speaking
and
he gets paid for it he donates a bunch
of the pay that he gets for the
unemployment relief he runs for senate
he loses
he supports the bonus army which was
when the world war one vets they had
these things called service certificates
that they that they bought
and when they bought those things
they had
again i'm sorry if this isn't perfect
but it was something along the lines of
when you bought these things they had
like a 20-year
maturity time on them
and the depression's going on
and everyone's like hey we want that
money and all these veterans
thousands and thousands of veterans are
saying hey we you know we gave you that
money we bought those service
certificates which are like bonds we
want we want to cash them in now
and the government was like hey those
are 20 years man you bought those 19 you
got another
you got another few years before you can
cash those things in
and this is when they had all the big
standoffs in the you know the world war
one veterans march down and set up camp
in washington dc and he he supported
that
gave more speeches
uh here's a here's an example this is
what is when we know where he's heading
mentally right
i don't mean that in a bad way i mean we
can see what
his angle starts to become this was and
this was a
summary of one of his speeches that was
published in socialist magazine that was
called common sense it says i spent 33
years and four months in active military
service and during that period i spent
most of my time as a high class muscle
man for big business for wall street and
the bankers in short i was a racketeer a
gangster for capitalism
i helped make mexico and especially
tampico which is a city in mexico safe
for american oil
ass interests in 1914. i helped make
haiti and cuba a decent place for the
national citibank boys to collect
revenues in i helped in the raping of
half a dozen central american republics
for the benefit of wall street
i helped purify nicaragua for the
international banking house of brown
brothers brothers in 1902 to 1912. i
brought light to the dominican republic
for the american sugar interest in 1916.
i helped make honduras right for the
american fruit companies in 1903
in china in 1927 i helped see to it that
standard oil went on its way unmolested
looking back on it i might have given al
capone a few hints
the best he could do was operate his
racket in three districts
i operated
on three continents
so he's kind of pissed
again this guy would have been all over
twitter 1934 he's sort of the leader of
this thing that was called the business
plot which was this
that there's this this conspiracy that
there was this plot for business leaders
to overthrow president roosevelt
and in
1935 he wrote this book
called
war is a racket
now
we're going gonna read it um
some of it's extreme
some of it may be too extreme some of
it's not accurate some of it's his
feelings his emotions
um
you know when
colonel david hackworth
when he
went and talked to
the press
and
you and i have had that discussion dave
like did he give up his influence he
could have been a division camera
brigade commander next and a division
commander
and and i think people sometimes reach a
point where they
emotionally
can't take it anymore and i think david
hackworth got there where he had had
seen enough
american soldiers and he loved so he
loved his soldiers and he loved all
soldiers and he loved the army and just
to see
the soldiers being utilized in a way
that he didn't think was tactically
sound eventually he just couldn't take
it anymore
and
i think that
major general smedley butler got to a
similar point
and of course this is 1935 so i mean we
got hitler in power in 1933.
so he sees though he hears the war drums
beating
and as he sees the war drums beating he
doesn't like it
what are your thoughts so far dave
it's interesting to hear you
recount some things that i remember
because obviously as a marine this is
one of the characters
in the history of the marine corps that
you are are given early on yeah so they
give it they give you smedley butler
early on oh yeah is there is there not
risk in that
aren't they like wow
yeah the weird thing was that we're at
the medal of honors right look i'm in no
position to be like well i'm not sure
but
when 46 navy sailors
got a medal of honor
and there's 17 killed in action like
that's a
that that seems very
seems very that seems that seems strange
yeah right seems strange and that's the
that's really kind of the point
that i'm thinking about in my mind is
you know there's a little bit of a
contrast
this is a guy that you you hear about
and certainly in and listen you could i
mean i got to be careful with my words
too because i don't want there to be a
negative connotation to it but there's a
there's an indoctrination you go through
and you're a marine and that
indoctrination is
we're kind of awesome and our history is
pretty awesome and we've got some
amazing people that did some amazing
things and you start to think about who
those people are one of the things
that's interesting about the name
smedley butler is when you see the
pictures of this guy like you'll be in a
class and it'll be about marine corps
history and they'll literally have a
slide or a picture up on the wall of the
person and he's not he doesn't really
look like a a
i guess he looks like a poster boy
marine he looks like a guy named smedley
he does that went to a maybe a private
school in this coast and and then
you know you're you're seeing bazz alone
and you're seeing chesty and these
pictures and just the pictures alone are
enough to be like okay this this dude is
legit
um
but you know they also
i i i don't have any recollection of of
the things that he did and the times
that he did them and the awards i don't
ever remember being given sort of the
other side of it was hey listen there's
a different time different circumstances
so
as i hear you talk about that and i'm
listening to that i just did some basic
math you know 50 600 people and then you
sort of did the w wounded and killed i'm
like no
i've seen that i know what the middle or
more of the other side of that looks
like and those numbers are good numbers
you know by by by standards like you
said this is probably not the most high
intensity thing that that that marines
have been through
but the other side is is
this is also i'm literally you just said
he's 48 years old he's a major general
there's a guy that went back in the
marine corps twice as a guy that left
high school and by rights could probably
just
coasted on a pretty easy life
um so you're kind of forced to reconcile
in your mind that
i i think
to maybe the whole point of this podcast
is i probably need to listen to what he
has to say
um but yeah i no he's he's he is one of
the characters that and i'm using that
term just you know to illustrate that we
are introduced to histori marines that
have have had impact in history
and that's someone that you we know
about for sure
we we could probably do a whole podcast
about awards and whatnot but
i forget what year like the bronze star
and the silver star it wasn't they
didn't have those yet at this time yeah
i think and so this was if you were
going to get an award it was going to be
the medal of honor
um
and there you go
again it's it's like crazy because you
got this guy that has two metal two
medals of honor and this marine corps
bravette thing which there's there's not
many of those things handed out either
it's it's a tiny number
and and also
the type of combat that they were going
into i mean this is pre-world war one is
the combat he's talking about so combat
was totally different
between
ah you know what i mean you got the
civil war we knew what combat was but
but
um
yeah there have been there'd been a
generation maybe that was a little bit
that that hadn't quite been there yeah
and i think the sense that i've always
had
was that the when you think of conflict
or you think of combat and you think of
world war one it has a very strong sense
of organized conflict between two
well-established well-organized size
sides that have
design and structure and and components
that you can almost align against each
other and that certainly for world war
one produces probably like the most
heavy intensity of conflict
whereas before that you have this sense
of this well-organized team the united
states navy the united states marine
corps the organization of those two
working together where we're gonna get
you to the beach you're gonna embark and
you're gonna or or debark and get onto
the land and we're gonna support you and
but the the
the people you're in conflict with
don't have that level of organization so
when you said um you know one wounded
on the good side and 57 killed i'm like
i can
and again i should be careful wounded by
a rock but you can picture that like
this is a lopsided scenario and it
doesn't mean that that weren't
incredibly brave actions that didn't
happen to solicit that outcome
but when you think of world war one and
world war ii or really conflicts we've
had since then that organized versus
organized you don't get those sense of
that long period of marine corps history
and those are all in marine corps
history we we've learned about all those
things
but
you don't get a sense of this force on
force conflict that we're near
traditional
um world war one world war ii we're
going against someone that's pretty much
like we are professionally trained
professionally outfitted and prepared
for for this type of conflict check so
he writes his book war as a racket and
people people i i don't know i've had
this book for five years um in fact i
couldn't even find i have two copies of
it and i had i wasn't able to find them
so you can get this thing on pdf
um
and the reason i couldn't find them is
because the moving scenario i'm going
through so all my books are in big giant
boxes
and i was like it's time to do it and
yeah what makes it time to do it because
well one of the things that just
totally provoked me was
a trillion dollar price tag on
afghanistan
and thousands of lives lost
and you're thinking hold on a second
who
what was what was the overall goal here
what are we doing because if i could
spend a trillion dollars and do
literally anything
you give me a trillion dollars a
trillion dollars
you're telling me you couldn't square
away a country with a trillion dollars
in 20 years and
basically an unlimited supply of people
and and assets it's crazy
so what was going on so as i'm thinking
about that
here i am a guy that's that supports the
military
that is very patriotic
and i'm thinking who spends a trillion
dollars
and and doesn't doesn't get the job done
how's that happen
who are you what are you thinking about
what is your ultimate goal
and that very quickly
my mind very quickly jumped on oh this
is probably what smelly but no i'd read
war as a racket i was always kind of
like yeah well yeah i mean that's one
way of looking at it right
so let's look at it
here we go chapter one war is a racket
it always has been
it is possibly the oldest easily the
most profitable surely the most vicious
it is the only one international in
scope it is the only one in which the
profits are reckoned in dollars and the
losses
in lives
a racket is best described i believe
as something that is not what it seems
to be to the majority of the people only
a small inside group knows what it's
about
it is conducted for the benefit of the
very few at the expense of the very many
out of war a few people make huge
fortunes
okay
if we're just going to fact check this
thing as we go
so far we are we are factual right
that's what a racket is right a racket
is something where a couple people kind
of know what's going on everyone else is
getting fooled the couple people
insiders are going to make a bunch of
money other people are kind of going to
get screwed that's what's going to
happen
in war there are people that make a lot
of money
he calls it the world war because there
was only one at the time in the world
war
a mere handful garnered the prophets of
the conflict
at least 21 000 new millionaires and
billionaires were made in the united
states during the world war
that many admitted their huge blood
gains
or sorry that many admitted their huge
blood gains in their income tax returns
how many other war millionaires
falsified their tax returns no one knows
okay so a lot of people made a lot of
money in the war i just saw an article
that
there's
several billion dollars
in taxes that are that are avoided
by the top one percent earners in this
country
so are there people that are doing
things to get around taxes yes
were there people that were made into
millionaires and billionaires after
september 11th
yes there were
next
how many of these war millionaires
shouldered a rifle
how many of them dug a trench how many
of them knew what it meant to go hungry
in a rat infested dugout
how many of them spent sleepless
frightened nights ducking shells and
shrapnel and machine gun bullets
how many of them parried a bayonet
thrust of an enemy
how many of them were wounded or killed
in battle
rhetorical questions that i think we all
know the answer to
not many
out of war
nations acquire additional territory if
they are victorious they just take it
this newly acquired territory promptly
exists is exploited by the few the
self-same few who run dollars out of
blood in the war
the general public shoulders the bill
fact check
kind of negative on this one
i mean
america speaking of america we haven't
we've we we kind of are established what
we have territory-wise and we haven't
taken any new territory in recent wars
that's not been our goal
so
and even you know
the idea that oh we're just going in
there to take the oil we don't actually
go in and take the oil it doesn't it
hasn't happened
and what is the bill
this bill renders a horrible accounting
newly placed gravestones
mangled bodies shattered minds broken
hearts and homes economic instability
depression and all its attendant
miseries
back-breaking taxation
for generations and generations
factually true
horrible accounting
and taxation to pay for these
wars for generations
for a great many years as a soldier i
had a suspicion that war was a racket
not until i retired to civil life did i
fully realize it
now that i see the international war
clouds gathering as they are today i
must face it and speak out
and again that's because he's looking at
world war ii
we call them the war clouds
again they are choosing sides france and
russia met and agreed to stand by
side by side italy and austria hurried
to make a similar agreement poland and
germany cast
cast sheep's eyes at each other
forgetting for the nonce their dispute
over the polish corridor and look what
nonce was
it means uh
it means like a one-time a one-time deal
just hey we're just going to forget
about our dispute over here because
we're going to be friends right now
assassination of king alexander of
yugoslavia complicated matters
yugoslavia and hungary hungary
long bitter enemies were almost at each
other's throats italy was ready to jump
in but france was waiting so was
czechoslovakia all of them are looking
ahead to war
not the people
not those who fight and pay and die only
those who foment wars and remain safely
at home
to profit
what do you got
are you gonna fact check that no no no
no
yeah yeah
i'm
i'm kind of sitting here listening to
you talk which is his work you read this
before no i have not so that's why this
is like a it's hard this is hard and so
i mean i wrote down a bunch of different
notes the last one i just wrote down was
was just literally the word angry like
and i don't i don't think you're trying
to convey that emotion on purpose it's
literally the words that you are reading
if you just
if you try to put yourself in his shoes
and i was just kind of recounting we
were talking about low intensity
conflict and maybe the things that
happened up until prior to world war one
and
and i did think of something after i i
was talking a minute ago about you know
the word low intensity conflict i do
remember the first time
i was shot at like for real
and
there's a moment when you're the one who
who is you know the victim or the
potential victim here it feels like
world war iii because when you're the
one being shot it doesn't really matter
the scope of what's going around you
that sense of things like oh damn those
people they're trying to kill me and
they're actually pretty darn close um
you don't say well you know in the grand
scheme of historical things this is a
very low intensity conflict and this
particular engagement isn't you don't
think like that you think okay this is a
big deal this is a huge deal and then
if you if you observe that in in your
own issues and you lead up to to the
travesty of world war one i'm just
trying to be empathetic to the level of
frustration you would have
at the hands of
a few number of decision makers both
military and civilian by the way when we
talked about world war one
it's not hard for me to try to
understand
that as he said i'm just almost
picturing him writing this down and just
the
just the frustration and the anger that
he has and how clearly that's coming
through and hearing you say his the
words that he's saying
um that it's hard not to to get a sense
of his frustration and and you've even
talked about with how hackworth is that
when you just kind of boil over you're
not able to really even articulate
yourself
i don't mean to say correctly but but
the way that you would normally want to
when you can keep your emotions in check
yeah which you can't yeah and i know you
gotta you found it very interesting when
we did when we talked about b.h la del
hart just the fact like once you
realized he was in the battle psalm
you're like oh got it okay so this guy
has a totally different perspective
which is completely
grounded and and
fermented in what he experienced on the
battlefield and yeah this is a yeah it's
definitely
it's definitely a similar a similar deal
moving on there are 40 million men under
arms in the world today so this again
this is 1935 and our statesmen and
diplomats
have the temerity to say that war is not
in the making
hell's bells are these 40 million men
being trained to be dancers
not in italy to be sure premier
mussolini knows what they are being
trained for he at least is frank enough
to speak out only the other day el duce
in international conciliation the
publication of the carnegie endowment
for international peace said quote and
above all fascism the more it considers
and observes the future and the
development of humanity quite apart from
political considerations of the moment
believes neither in the possibility nor
the utility of perpetual peace
war alone brings up to its highest
tension all human energy and puts the
stamp of nobility upon the people who
have the courage to meet it
end quote
that's a
it's one thing for ronald reagan to say
peace through strength and hey we've got
to be strong and we've got to you know
the best way to to avoid war is to be
prepared for it but when you got
mussolini just saying hey there's i
don't believe in the possibility or the
or the freaking utility of peace
war alone brings to its highest tension
all human energy
and puts the stamp of nobility upon the
people who have the courage to meet it
that's the leader of your country guess
what's happening you're going to war
undoubtedly mussolini means exactly what
he says his well-trained army his great
fleet of planes and even his navy are
ready for war anxious for it apparently
his recent stand at the side of hungary
in the latter's dispute with yugoslavia
showed that and the hurried mobilization
of troops on the austrian border after
the assassination of dolphus showed it
too
there are others in europe whose saber
rattling presages war sooner or later
hair hitler
with his rearming germany and his
constant demands for more and more arms
is an equal if not greater menace to
peace france only recently increased the
term of military service for its youth
from a year to 18 months
all this stuff is going on he's just
tracking it
he sees everybody's just heading to war
yes all over nations are camping in
their arms
the mad dogs of europe are on the loose
in the orient the maneuvering is more a
droid back in 1904 when russia and japan
fought we kicked our old friends the
russians and back japan
then our very generous international
bankers were financing japan now the
trend is to poison us against the
japanese
what does the open door policy to china
mean to us our trade with china is about
90 million dollars a year
or the philippine islands we have spent
about 600 million dollars in the
philippines in 35 years and we our
bankers and industrialists and
speculators have private investments
there of less than 200 million
then to save china to save that china
trade of about 90 million and to protect
these private investments of less than
200 in the philippines
we would all be stirred up to hate japan
and go to war a war that might well cost
us tens of billions of dollars hundreds
of thousands of american lives
and many more hundreds of thousands of
physically maimed and mentally
unbalanced men
of course for this loss there would be a
compensating profit fortunes would be
made millions and billions of dollars
would be pi piled up
by a few
munitions makers bankers ship builders
manufacturers meat packers speculators
they would fare well
yes they are getting ready for another
war why shouldn't they
it pays high dividends
but what does it profit the men who are
killed what does it profit their mothers
and sisters their wives and their
sweethearts what does it profit their
children
what does it profit anyone except the
very few
to whom war means huge profits
yes
and what does it profit the nation
so
i kind of have my thoughts on all this
that i'm gonna save a little bit
um
but what's what's what's the the
i would say the methodology of the
argument that he's presenting
is to show one side of the argument
which is very it's a good argument
i mean you can't you can't really
you can't really come at this argument
you can't say well people aren't going
to make money no people make money
that's what happens
and that by itself isn't automatically a
bad thing either this is true that's the
other that's the other part that's what
i'm saying like
there's i know you've got thoughts on
this soon i got to be careful i could
probably chime in like i usually do on
every single thing that's said and
there's thoughts going through my head
like crazy
yes
yeah i mean there are profiteers and
there are people that profit and and
if i'm using the terms correctly you can
distinguish between those two right and
they can be aligned
for sure i mean
it's easy for me to sit here in
retrospect but it's like hey hitler
mussolini yeah we probably want to go to
one of those people yeah now not yet let
them do what they want that's not a good
plan and i know this now sitting here
looking back
but you're right and and
i think to your point
his perspective is
correct it's not the whole story but
it's a perspective that what he sees and
the way he's presenting it is correct
yes it's just that there is more there's
more to it and as you said there's
nothing more obvious than that than a
guy named adolf hitler right that's
about to go on a tear yeah and kill
millions of people and it's interesting
he's using him like hey he might be
worse than this other guy yeah he might
be yeah in 1935 he didn't seem so bad
compared to mussolini
he's going to give a little example
example here take our own case
until until 1898 we didn't own a bit of
territory outside the mainland of north
america at that time our national debt
was a little more than a billion dollars
then we became internationally minded we
forgot or shunted aside the advice of
the father of our country we forgot
george washington's warning about
entangling alliances we went to war
we acquired outside territory at the end
of the world war period as a direct
result of our fiddling in international
affairs our national debt had jumped to
over 25 billion
our total favorable trade balance during
the 25-year period was about 24 billion
therefore on a purely bookkeeping basis
we ran a little behind year for year
and that foreign trade might as well
have been ours without the wars
again when you just look at the numbers
to run the numbers
man we're we were a billion dollars in
that debt and now we're 25 billion
dollars in debt that hurts
it would have been far cheaper
not to say safer for the average
american who pays the bills to stay out
of forward entanglements
for very few this racket like
bootlegging and other underworld rackets
brings fancy profits but the cost of
operations is always transferred to the
people who do not profit
and now we get into chapter two who
makes the profits
the world war
rather our brief participation in it has
cost the united states some 52 billion
dollars figured out that means 400
dollars to every american man woman and
child and we haven't paid the debt yet
we are paying it our children will pay
it and our children's children
probably still will be paying the cost
of that war
the normal profits of a business concern
in the united states are 6 8 10 and
sometimes 12 percent
but wartime profits ah that is another
matter 20 60 100 300 and even 1800
the sky is the limit all that traffic
will bear uncle sam has the money let's
get it
of course
it isn't put that crudely in wartime
it is dressed into speeches about
patriotism love of country and quote we
must all put our shoulders to the wheel
but the prophets jump and leap and
skyrocket
and are safely pocketed let's just take
a few examples take our friends the
duponts the powder people
didn't one of them testify before a
senate committee recently that their
powder won the war or saved the world or
saved the world for democracy or
something
how did they do in the war
they were a patriotic corporation well
the average earnings of the duponts for
the period of 1910 to 1914 was 66
million dollars a year
it wasn't much but the duponts managed
to get along
now let's look at their average yearly
profit during the war years 1914 to
1918.
58 million dollars of profit
a year we find nearly 10 times that of
normal times and the profits of normal
times were pretty good
an increase of profits more than 950
percent
take one of our little steel companies
that patriotically shunted aside the
making of rails and girders and bridges
to manufacturing war materials well
their 1910 to 1914 yearly earnings
averaged six million dollars then came
the war and like loyal citizens
bethlehem steel promptly turned to
mission munitions making did their
profits jump or did they let or did they
let uncle sam in for a bargain well
their 1914 to 1918 average was 49
million a year oh let's take united
steel
normal earnings during the five-year
period prior to the war were 105 million
dollars a year not bad
then came along the war
and up with the profits the average
yearly profit for the period 1914 to
1918 was 240 million not bad
then you have some of the steel and
powder earnings
let's look at some let's look at
something else a little copper perhaps
that always does well in war times
anaconda for instance average yearly
earnings during the pre-year pre-year
wars of 1910 to 1914 10 million
during the war years 1914 and 1918
profits slept to 34 million dollars a
year utah copper average of 5 million
during the pre-war period
jumped to an average of 21 million
yearly profits for the war period
let's group these five with three
similar companies the total yearly
average profits of the pre-war period
1910 to 1914 were 137 million then came
along the war the average yearly profits
for this group skyrocketed to 408
million
a little increase in profits of
approximately 200 percent
does war pay they paid them
but they aren't the only ones there are
still others let's take leather
for a three-year period the before the
war the total profits of central leather
company were 3.5 million
that was approximately 1.16 million
dollars a year well in 1916 central
leather returned a profit of 15 million
a spelling small increase of 1 100
that's all a general chemical the
general chemical company averaged a
profit for three years before the war of
a little over eight hundred thousand
dollars a year came the war and profits
jumped to 12 million dollars a year a
leap of 1400
international nickel company you can't
have a war without nickel showed an
increase in profits from a mere 4
million a year to 73 million a year
not bad an increase of one thousand
seven hundred percent american sugar
refining company averaged two million
dollars a year for three years before
the war in 1916 a profit of six million
dollars was recorded
listen to senate document number 259 the
65th congress congress reporting on
corporate earnings and government
revenues considering the profits of 122
meat packers 153 cotton manufacturers
299 garment makers 49 steel plants 340
coal producers during the war profits
under 25 percent were exceptional
for instance the coal companies made
between 100 and 7
800 percent on their capital stock
during the war the chicago packers
doubled and tripled their earnings let
us not forget the bankers who financed
the great war if anyone cream if anyone
had the cream of the profits it was the
bankers being partnerships rather than
incorporated organizations they did not
have to report to stockholders and their
profits
were as secret as they were immense
how the bankers made their millions and
billions i do not know because those
little secrets never become public even
before a senate investor
investigatory body
people make money
i mean and part of that is supply and
demand
and one of the reasons that america does
so well during war is because we have
capitalism and that's how we're able to
out produce other countries
even i mean especially companies that
have
socialized or communist controlled
industry they just can't do what we do
why because they're not driven to do it
there's no
hey
look i'm running this factory for
whatever for the soviet union they want
me to make 100 tanks they want me to
make 200 tanks i'm going to get the same
paycheck regardless and if i'm a guy
whatever
working on the
the the fabrication of one of those tank
treads i don't care if i make 20 today
or if i make 100 today
i
i'm going to get the same paycheck
so
these people are going to make a lot of
money because they're going to turn out
something that is in high demand
here's how some other patriotic
industrialists and speculators chiseled
their way into war profits take the shoe
people they like war
it brings business with abnormal profits
they made huge profits and sales abroad
to our allies perhaps like the munitions
manufacturers and arm armor makers they
also sold to the enemy for a dollar is a
dollar whether it comes from germany or
from france
but they did well by uncle sam too for
instance they sold uncle sam
35 million pairs of hobnailed service
shoes
so that's a big
number there were four million soldiers
eight pairs or more to a soldier my
regiment during the war had only one
pair to soldier
per soldier some of these shoes probably
are still in existence they were good
shoes but when the war was over uncle
sam has a matter of 25 million pairs of
shoes left over bought and paid for
profits recorded and pro and pocketed
and this is you should start getting
into the idea of just like the
government waste and it's just the crazy
crazy government waste
which is why
the free market is so powerful
because people try and streamline things
there was a lot of leather left so the
leather people sold your uncle sam
hundreds of thousands of mcclellan
saddles for the cavalry but there wasn't
any american cavalry overseas somebody
had to get rid of this leather however
somebody had to make a profit in it so
we had a lot of mcclellan saddles
we probably still do also somebody made
a lot of mosquito netting they sold
uncle sam 20 million mosquito nets for
the use of soldiers overseas i suppose
the boys were expected to put it over
them as they tried to sleep in muddy
trenches
one hand scratching cooties on their
backs and the others making passes at
scurrying rats well not one of these
mosquito nets ever got to france
anyhow these thoughtful manufacturers
wanted to make sure that no soldier
would be without his mosquito net so 40
million additional yards of mosquito
netting were sold uncle
sam
you know why cause you're not spending
your own money
you're not spending your own money when
you're not spending your own money man
you spend it on stuff
because it's really easy you know what
they might need them
you know what let's get them
and all politics are local and who knows
who was putting in those where those
mosquito nets were made
these were pretty good profits in
mosquito netting in those days even if
there were no mosquitoes in france i
suppose if the ward lasted just a little
bit longer the enterprising mosquito
netting manufacturers would have sold
uncle sam a couple of consignments of
mosquitoes to plant in france so that
more mosquito netting would be in order
airplane and air and engine
manufacturers felt they too should
adjust their profits out of this war why
not everybody else is getting theirs
so a billion dollars count them if you
live long enough was spent by uncle sam
and building airplane engines that never
left the ground not one plane or motor
out of the billion dollars worth ordered
ever got into battle in france
just the same the manufacturers made
their little profit of 30 100 or perhaps
300 percent
remember the fraud waste and abuse
hotline apparently they didn't have that
like in the military echo charles they
got a thing called the fraud waste and
abuse hotline
you call up and say hey we're buying
plane engines we got them lined up we're
not using them we're buying mosquito
nets
we're not using them did anyone actually
use that or do you know of anyone who i
never used did you ever use it i never
use it but i know the sticker on the
wall
i know if i would have had to use it i'd
probably use it on my tasking or my
platoon for the money we were wasting on
ammunition
just
slaying ammunition
undershirts for soldiers cost 14 cents
to make and uncle sam paid 30 to 40
cents each for them a nice little profit
for the undershirt manufacturer and the
stocking manufacturer the uniform
manufacturers and the cap manufacturer
and the steel helmet manufacturers all
got theirs
why when the war was over
some four million sets of equipment
knapsacks and things that go to fill
them crammed warehouses on this side now
they are being scrapped because the
regulations have changed the contents
but the manufacturers collected their
wartime profits on them and they will do
it all over again next time
there were lots of brilliant ideas for
making profit during the war one very
versatile patriot sold uncle sam 12
dozen 48 inch wrenches oh they were very
nice wrenches the only trouble was that
there was only one nut ever made that
was large enough for these wrenches
that's the one that holds the turbines
at niagara falls well after uncle sam
had bought them and manufactured and the
manufacturer had profited from them the
wrenches were put on freight cars and
shunted all around the united states in
an effort to find a use for them when
the armistice was signed it was indeed a
sad blow to the wrench manufacturer he
was just about to make some nuts to fit
the wrenches
then he planned to sell those too to
your uncle sam
still another brilliant idea that the
colonels shouldn't ride in automobiles
nor should they even ride on horseback
one has probably seen a picture of andy
jackson riding on a buck board well some
six thousand buck boards were sold to
uncle sam for the use by kernels not one
of them was used
the buck board manufacturer got his war
profit
board is like a wagon it's like a
carriage with leaf springs to be towed
behind a horse six thousand of them
the shipbuilders felt they should come
on on some of it too they built a lot of
ships that they made a lot of profit
more than 3 billion worth some of the
ships were all right
but 635 million worth of them were made
of wood that wouldn't float the seams
opened up and they sank we paid for them
though and somebody pocketed the profits
it's been estimated by statisticians and
economists and researchers that the war
cost your uncle sam 52 billion dollars
of this sum 39 billion was expended in
the actual war itself this expenditure
yielded 16
billion dollars in profits
that is how the 21
000 billionaires and millionaires
got that way
this 16 billion dollars in profits is
not to be sneezed at it's quite a tidy
sum and it went to a very few
the senate committee
probe of the munitions industry and its
wartime profits despite its sensational
closures
hardly had scratched the surface
even so it's had some effect the state
department had been studying for some
time methods of keeping out of war the
war department suddenly decides it has a
wonderful plan to spring the
administration names a committee with
the war navy departments ably
represented under the chairmanship of a
wall street speculator to limit profits
in wartime
to what extent isn't suggested hmm
possibly the profits of 300 and 600 and
of those who turned blood into gold in
world war in the world war would be
limited to some smaller figure
apparently however the plan does not
call for any limitation of losses that
is the loss losses of those who fight
the war
as far as i have been able to ascertain
there is nothing in this scheme to limit
a soldier to the loss of but one eye or
one arm or to limit his wounds to one or
two or three or to limit the loss of
life
there's nothing in this scheme
apparently that says not more than 12
percent of a regiment shall be wounded
in bottle or not more than seven percent
of a division shall be killed
of course the committee cannot be
bothered with such trifling matters
so they put together a committee and say
well you know they're making a little
too much money we should put a limit on
how much money they can make
possibly limit those war profits
[Applause]
chapter three
who pays the bills
who provides the profits these nice
little profits of 20 100 300 1500 1800
we all pay them in taxation
we paid the bankers their profits when
we bought liberty bonds at 100
and sold them back at 84 or 86 to the
bankers
these bankers collected dollars plus it
was a simple manipulation the bankers
controlled the security marts
it was easy for them to depress the
price of these bonds then all of us the
people got frightened and sold the bonds
at 84.86 the bankers bought them
then these same bankers stimulated a
boom and government bonds went to par
and above and then the bankers collected
their profits
but the soldier pays the biggest part of
the bill
if you don't believe this visit the
american cemeteries on the battlefields
abroad
or visit any of the veterans hospitals
in the united states
on a tour of the country in the midst of
which i am
i am doing at the time of writing this i
have visited 18 government hospitals for
veterans
in them are a total of about 50 000
destroyed men
men who were the pick of the nation 18
years ago
the very able chief surgeon at the
government hospital at milwaukee where
there are 3 800 of the living dead told
me that mortality among veterans is
three times as great as among those who
stayed at home
so this was interesting because
we we hear a lot about what happens when
we come home we hear about ptsd
and you you see like the images of shell
shock in world war ii especially in
england and the brits
you don't hear a lot about it from world
war one
and
this this is a weirdly written sentence
i tried to read it in a way that made it
made sense but it says the very able
surgeon the variable chief surgeon at
the government hospital semicolon at
milwaukee
where
there are 3 800 of the living dead told
me that the mortality among veterans is
three times as great as among those who
stayed at home so what he's saying is
people that fought are three times
likely to die
three times more likely to die than
someone that didn't fight
he doesn't talk about how
but my guess is a lot of those are
suicide
or just like the crazy violent deaths
that military people that have that
experience end up having
and here he goes into it a little bit
in the most simplistic and so
obvious
way
boys with a normal viewpoint
were taken out of the fields and offices
and factories and classrooms and put
into the ranks
they were remolded
they were made over
they were made to about face
to regard murder as the order of the day
they were put shoulder to shoulder and
through mass psychology
they were entirely changed
[Music]
we used them for a couple years and
trained them to think nothing at all of
killing or of being killed
then
suddenly
we discharged them and told them to make
another about-face
this time they had to do their own
readjustment without mass psychology
without officers aid and advice and
without nationwide propaganda
we didn't need them anymore
so we scattered them about with any
three-minute or liberty loan speeches or
without any three-minute or liberty loan
speeches or parades
many too many of these fine young boys
are eventually destroyed mentally
because they could not make that final
about face alone
that's pretty straightforward
and he gives a
example here he says in the government
hospital in marion indiana
1 800 of these boys are in pens
500 of them in a barracks with steel
bars and wires all around the outside of
the buildings and on the porches
these already have been mentally
destroyed these boys don't even look
like human beings oh the look on their
faces
physically are in good shape mentally
they are gone
there are thousands and thousands of
these cases and more and more are coming
in all the time
the tremendous excitement of the war the
sudden cutting off of that excitement
the young boys couldn't stand it
i'm gonna have to dig into that i have
to get some research going on that
because that sounds horrific
got 1800 men boys he's calling them but
but this is
1935 you know the war ended in 1918 so
he's
these are young men
and you just don't hear about this
you hear about it now
you don't hear about it from world war
one
and in fact world war ii i've talked
about like well you know in world war ii
you got to come home on a ship with some
other guys and you got to decompress for
five or six weeks and you you are held
up as a hero and all this stuff and
that's why it was easier to adapt it's
like uh what about world war one
and that freaking psychotic war
yeah i mean everything that's in my mind
obviously has to be tempered with the
fact that i truly cannot
claim to appreciate
the reality that he's describing
he yeah he said he's been basically
talking about va hospitals he's been to
18 different va hospitals this is a
passion for him he's going around seeing
what's going on
and
at least in this sense of of when you
think about world war ii that there was
this
and i got to assume it was felt at the
time this very clear sense
of good and evil right and wrong and the
sides that we are on and the the the
the justification
and the necessity the global necessity
and if you think about world war one to
at least try to reconcile the loss and
what was it for and what was really at
stake and how much blurrier just
you don't feel that in world war one and
you talk about probably a nation that's
just totally ill-equipped to have a
25-year-old come back after seeing what
they saw
without even be able to say hey i at
least saved the world
you know
from
holocaust or
nuclear war whatever could have been at
stake by the end of world war ii
and being totally ill-equipped to know
how to even handle that
at least in modern times right
you're at least a little bit
desensitized right you've seen horror
movies you've seen blood and guts you're
playing first person shooter video games
like this is can you imagine coming from
freaking
omaha nebraska where you're like
going to school you you know i mean
you're just a a normal kid that might
not even be the best example because at
least in omaha nebraska you're you're
slaughtering pigs
you're shooting guns but if you're in
whatever if you're from the city
and you just you're just not around that
you're not seeing it
and then boom you're thrown into world
war one yeah
and there was another section that he
that uh that i know about smelly butler
there was a point i think it was when he
was in china where
he for the first time saw like mass
slaughtered japanese
and it's just one of those points that
he had seen some real
violence and that was before world war
one
but
yeah at least nowadays
this might be a bad thing
is that people are desensitized somewhat
you know go on
go on
um whatever youtube i don't know does
youtube filter out like uh heinous
shootings and stuff like that yeah so
where do you see stuff like that now
oddly and i don't want to go too deep
into it but oddly they had a few
websites out there that you could just
go yeah
they say click here make sure you're 18
whatever yeah and then you can watch
whatever sick video you want but
as i've noticed not that i frequent
these things but as i've noticed they've
been kind of disappearing yeah that's
interesting like i remember there was a
video of a of a
a russian soldier
being killed by a
by a cheshian yeah and it's brutal
they're putting his boot on his head and
they're just he's screaming and they're
cutting his throat and he's sort of like
slowly
the impact of the knife blade yeah
that's old school there's way worse
stuff i'm saying that's old school but i
haven't seen that in a long time
and but i'm sure there's like some
websites where you can see all that
stuff yeah and i
like i said i think they're kind of
quietly doing away with them
maybe because they encourage certain
like groups to be like oh let's see if
we can put ours up you know because in
that dark area of the internet it's like
the people who are responsible for
making those videos
um sometimes they get into these little
competitions to see who can make the
sickest video
well and they go hard for sure even if
you just saw rated r movies yeah
you would be more accustomed to this
kind of
scenery oh yeah and and you got you have
like
like yeah the exposure of what war
actually is is way more now compared to
yeah time like hey if you watched um
saving private ryan yeah you're like
okay man i mean this is oh yeah and
there's reports plenty of reports that
world war ii veterans that were at d-day
were totally you know thought that
nailed it and they were very disturbed
in watching it
and had to take a break had to walk out
whatever because it was so realistic so
that's going to condition you yeah but
if you leave
freaking
maryland
where you live in a small neighborhood
and your dad works at the factory and
next thing you know you're in world war
one
and then and then all of a sudden three
weeks later you're back back in maryland
in your neighborhood it's gonna be a
rough one that's a good way to put it i
was like hey they take you out of your
normal world and make you do an about
face with all this essential training
and like all this cook you know
this influence and stuff and then when
that's done just all of a sudden hey do
another about face but hey do it on your
own kind of a thing it's like dang
that's exactly what happens huh you know
that song by the white buffalo that he
played when he was on here it's called
wish it was true
yeah well when he was on here he played
that song and and i actually had like
asked him to play the slow one yeah
and um but the song you know it's got a
line in there that basically says hey
you're just a number and we used you and
you're through and there's a couple
people that you know left some comments
or hit me up like this is an anti-war
song what are you talking about i was
like hey bro
this is what happens
it doesn't happen all the time but this
is a this is a song written from
someone's individual viewpoint of hey
went to war whatever war it was maybe
world war one world war ii world war
korea vietnam there was plenty of people
that went to those wars
came home and this is exactly what
happened that's what that song is about
it's not saying oh you you just got used
by the every single soldier's not saying
that
but there are this happens
this does happen and that's why it's
such a powerful song
this might sound a little bit
insensitive but you know you don't
ramble
that's what that story was essentially
about it is when you watch first blood
yeah right like that's essentially what
it was about and then they'd then they
of course they do them dirty again send
them to jail then rambo two they're like
oh wait wait we need that guy again you
know let's go get that guy and then they
do them try to do them dirty again see
i'm saying that is essentially the story
yeah and it's not and and look there's
plenty of people that come home from war
and they get
they they're able to deal with it and
they go cool you know what i did what i
had to do and now i'm going back to the
work and i'm going back to the factory
i'm going back to the construction site
going back to the to the insurance
business that i'm running or that i work
at it's people people do and they also
saw different things what did this
person see they'll do different things
what did this person do so we got to
take all these things into account but
like you just pointed out echo the fact
that you're going to take hundreds of
thousands of people
in world war one in world war ii you can
take hundreds of thousands of people
and train them to kill
and then when it's over you're like cool
we're good hey appreciate it see you
later
and i mean i don't
uh
eugene sledge
i mean he had a really hard time when he
came home from war
a really hard time when he came home
from war and he still carried on with
his normal life i mean actually all
those guys did
um all those guys that were over over
there had a real hard time but there's
also
millions of veterans that came home and
like
they carried on with their life you know
i mean
um
i i i mean i've had him on this podcast
i mean charlie plum how has he come home
from six years of captivity and just
like okay cool well you know do you know
we're gonna move on yeah
william reader
by the way william reader 40 years like
stayed in the army for another whatever
38 years
doing his job getting a fit rep how do
you write a fit rep for for william
reader how do you not just say hey sir
what look i'm supposed to be in charge
of you you tell me what you want to do
because you have done more than
for the military than i could have ever
hoped to have done and i appreciate you
sitting here and not like
not like beating me up or whatever not
not counseling me on what an idiot i am
so there's plenty of people that come
home and they they all right now i will
say this and charlie plum pointed this
out to me
their
the amount of like
post-traumatic stress that the guys that
were in the hanoi hilton had was less on
average than normal
infantrymen
and it's because they had this
camaraderie
at least that's what he said at least i
think i remember what he said but but
they had this camaraderie so it was like
hey you know we were all and they had
time to process it
and
and then they got this huge beautiful
welcome home
[Music]
and i mean when i uh it was jim sterlsey
i think it was jim sterlsey when he you
know he's lost both legs and his arm and
the guys came home from
being pows with the white you know with
the big reception and he was like hey
bro
uh i understand you guys were held
captive i'm sorry um
you know i
i got back and just
went to a freaking rehab for nine months
and then i'm out here with one
arm
so
that probably helped the the guys that
were capped captives in in in vietnam as
well is that they got a very warm
welcome home and as we know a lot of
vietnam veterans did not get a warm
welcome home
and i
from what it sounds like here same thing
world war one
oh the look on their faces physically
they're in good shape mentally they are
gone yeah
i wrote that down too that that
the metaphor that he describes about we
take them we have him doing about face
and then we have him doing another about
face and it's they can't do that second
one we have them do the second one on
their own on their own they can't do it
it's not unreasonable to think and just
i was literally just thinking about what
who are you if you're a 21 22 year old
male in 1914 going to world war one who
who are you and and it's
it's not unreasonable to think that they
had no idea what war was period
what war was and if you think about
today like
joining the military to your point
at least
some exposure is accessible to anybody
you have some idea what war is you've
seen platoon you've seen full metal
jacket you've seen save in private ryan
you've seen apocalypse now you've seen
all these movies yes
and it's in the national psyche people
are talking about it people have been
talking about it if you were in world
war one and you're 20
i mean the last
yeah there's historians probably do some
math but like this unless you have some
connection to the civil war which ended
50 years ago and you're getting stories
from your grandpa you have no idea what
war is and then you're going to world
war one
where
the use of human capital the the use of
a human being was was
less significant than than any other
piece of material that was out there
and and today like i
i did 23 years in the marine corps i
retired like five years like 30 years
coming up on my military experience
we take excessive sometimes tactically
unsound lengths to preserve
american lives now obviously we know
that doesn't always work out but
we don't
by design waste lives and you can kind
of almost count on that like hey there
there are no more human waves there's no
hey listen
gents have a seat let's talk about this
plan
we know we're all going to get wiped out
but we have to go do this like those
conversations aren't really happening
and so you kind of know what you're
getting into a little bit at least
softens out a little bit you know what
war is some idea what the word's gonna
be like i can't imagine a bigger
contrast of being 19 years old hey
you're going to europe like hey
where is that okay cool it's here hey
what country is that
that's this country here okay who are we
fighting
these people over here oh how is this
going to work well when you get there
we'll show you okay
cool and then and then and then you see
world war one yeah
the second about face to do on your own
yeah it's gonna be a rough it's not
gonna work out right and he's now
touring the country going
yeah
and and yeah the frustration is should
we probably take a couple of those
dollars i mean the sarcasm with which
does this so should we take a couple of
those dollars and maybe help these folks
with that about face
these patriots over here making money
again and this is just me saying
i can appreciate this point of view get
where he's coming get where he's coming
from
and this is this is not some coward this
is not some um this is not a dude who's
sitting on the sidelines casting
judgment this is a guy who who for
whatever
got back in the this is a guy who can
speak you know from a first person point
of view certainly can
so he gets done talking about that part
of the bill and he says that's a part of
the bill
so much for the dead they have paid
their part of the war profits so much
for the mentally and physically wounded
they are paying now for their share of
the war prophets
but others paid too they paid with
heartbreaks when they tore themselves
away from their firesides and their
families to don the uniform of uncle sam
on which a prophet had been made
they paid another part in the training
camps where they were regimented and
drilled while others took their jobs and
their places in their lives and in their
communities they paid for it in the
trenches where they were shot at and
they were shot where they were hungry
for days at a time where they slept in
mud and cold and rain
with the moans and shrieks of the dying
for a horrible lullaby
but don't forget the soldier paid part
of the dollars and cents bill too
up to and including the spanish-american
war we had a prize system and soldiers
and sailors fought for money
during the civil war they were paid
bonuses in many instances before they
went into service
the government or the states paid as
high as twelve hundred dollars for an
enlistment
in the spanish-american war they gave
prize money
when we captured any vesseled vessels
the soldiers all got their share at
least they were supposed
to then it was found we could reduce the
cost of wars by taking all the prize
money and keeping it
but constricted conscripting
the soldiers anyway so just going to the
draft then soldiers couldn't bargain for
their labor either
everyone else could bargain
but the soldier couldn't
napoleon once said all men are enamored
of decorations they positively hunger
for them so by developing a napoleonic
system the metal business the government
learned it could get soldiers for less
money because the boys liked to be
decorated
until the civil war there were no medals
then the congressional medal of honor
was handed out it made enlistments
easier after the civil war no new medals
were issued until the spanish-american
war
in the world war we used propaganda to
make the boys
accept conscription
they were made to feel ashamed if they
didn't join the army
so vicious was this war propaganda that
even god was brought into it with a few
with few exceptions our clergymen joined
in the clamor to kill kill kill to kill
the germans god is on our side it is his
will that the german should be killed
and in germany the good pastors called
upon the germans to kill the allies to
please the same god
that was part of the general propaganda
built up to make
people war conscious and murder
conscious
beautiful ideals were painted for our
boys who were sent out to die this was
the war to end all wars
this was the war to make the world safe
for democracy
no one mentioned to them as they marched
away that their going and dying would
mean huge war profits no one told these
american soldiers that they might be
shot down by bullets made by their own
brothers here no one told them that the
ships on which they were going to cross
might be torpedoed by submarines built
with united states patents
they were just told it was going to be a
glorious adventure
thus having stuffed patriotism down
their throats it was decided to make
them help pay for the war too so we gave
them a large salary of 30 a month all
they had to do for this
magnificent sum
was to leave their dear ones behind give
up their jobs lie in swampy trenches eat
canned willy when they could get it
and kill and kill and kill and be killed
but wait half that wage
just a little more than a river in a
shipyard or a labor and a munitions
factory safe at home made in a day half
that wage was promptly taken from him to
support his dependents so that he would
not become a charge upon his community
then we made him pay what amounted to
accident insurance something the
employer pays for an enlightened state
and that cost him about six dollars a
month
he had less than nine dollars a month
left
then the most crowning insolence of all
he was virtually blackjacked into paying
for his own ammunition clothing and food
by being made by being made to buy
liberty bonds most soldiers got no money
at all on paydays
we made them buy back but we made them
buy liberty bonds for a hundred dollars
and then we bought them back when they
came back from the war and couldn't find
work at
84.86
and the soldiers brought about about two
billion dollars worth of these bonds
yes the soldier pays the greater part of
the bill his family pays to they paid in
the same heartbreak that he does as he
suffers they suffer at nights as he lay
in the trenches and watch shrapnel burst
about him they lay home in their beds
and toss sleeplessly his father his
mother his wife his sisters his brothers
his sons and his daughters
when he returned home minus an eye or
minus a leg or with his mind broken they
suffered too
as much
and sometimes even more than he
yes and they too contributed their
dollars to the profits of the munition
makers and bankers and shipbuilders and
the manufacturers and the speculators
made they too bought liberty bonds and
contributed to the profit of the bankers
after the armistice in the hocus post
pocus of manipulated liberty bond
prices and even now the families of the
wounded men and of the mentally broken
and those who were never able to
readjust themselves are still suffering
and pain
fact check
i'm gonna go ahead and say truth
so what's going on
chapter four
how to smash this racket
well it's a racket all right
a few profit and the many pay
but there is a way to stop it
you can't end it by a disarmament
conference you can't eliminate it by
peace parleza geneva well-meaning but
impractical groups can't wipe it out by
resolutions it can be smashed
effectively only by taking the profit
out of war
the only way to smash this racket is to
conscript capital and industry and labor
before nations manhood can be
conscripted and there's just an
interesting thing i got to point out
when he talks about capital industry and
labor
he's talking about those groups of
people and i'm not going to change it
would be saying like the capitalists and
the industrialists and the and the labor
force
you you could say that but that's what
he there's the words he uses his capital
industry he's talking about those people
one month before the government can
conscript the young men of the nation it
must conscript capital and industry and
labor let the officers and the directors
and the high-powered executives of our
armament factories and munition makers
and our shipbuilders and airplane
builders and the manufacturers of all
other things that provide profit and
wartime as well as the bankers and the
speculators be conscripted to get 30 a
month the same wage as the lads and the
trenches get
but the workers in these plants get the
same wages all the workers all
presidents all executives all directors
all managers all bankers yes and all
generals and admirals and officers and
all politicians and all government
officer office holders everyone in the
nation can be restricted to a total
monthly income not to be not to exceed
that paid to the soldier in the trenches
let all these kings and tycoons and
masters of business and all those
workers in industry and all our senators
and governors and majors pay half of
their monthly thirty dollar wage to
their families and pay war risk
insurance and buy liberty bonds why
shouldn't they
they aren't running the risk of being
killed or having their bodies mangled or
their minds shattered they aren't
sleeping in muddy trenches they aren't
hungry the soldiers are
give capital and industry and labor 30
days to think it over and you will find
by that time there will be no war that
will smash the racket that and nothing
else
maybe i'm a little too optimistic
capital still has some say so capital
won't permit the taking of profit out of
war until the people those who do the
suffering and still pay the price make
up their minds that those they elect to
office shall do their bidding and not
that of the profiteers
you know so here you get to like a
a kind of a
um an argument you know that's like
hyperbole right hey what you need to do
is first just if you're going to go and
and if you know no one will argue with
it because it makes sense but it's just
it's
it's just an unrealistic thing to think
about um
unfortunately
guys we all get the idea yep you want to
go you want to go to war cool and he's
the interesting he's not even talking
about them going to war he's just
talking about you just get the pay for
and he's only talking about for 30 days
he's only talking about 30 years 30 days
you know you're the ceo of a of a
defense company for 30 days you're gonna
get
this pay
i actually don't think that's enough
right now i think it'd have to be a lot
more
you know you always hear that
and actually
when when you when you read about the
vietnam war
one of the things that really started to
turn the tide of the american public
against the vietnam war was
the draft
because all of a sudden it wasn't just
you know the the freaking poor redneck
from west virginia or the inner city
black kid from harlem that was getting
shipped off the water all of a sudden it
was like oh
you're in a you're from
wherever
and you're your dad is a lawyer your dad
is a judge your dad is a business owner
and you got a bunch of money and guess
what yep yeah
load up
load up on the bus because it's time to
go get some
and that star as that expanded
and normal
richer people started going to war
it was like the rich kids the rich
parents started sending their kids off
to work that's a problem and that's one
of the things that started to push the
the
the resistance
against the vietnam war
because when it was just hey we're
sending a bunch of damn poor people
hey cool whatever that's not my kid my
kid's not my kid's going to freaking
uh uh college next year he's not going
to boot camp he's not going to nom so i
don't care yeah it seems like a great
idea let's stop communism over there
until little johnny gets freaking called
up and then they're like oh maybe not so
i would say from that perspective that's
that that's a good assessment
realistic assessment that if you start
saying oh yeah you want to said do you
want to send america to war cool your
kid goes
people start changing their freaking
minds real quick
factually
he doesn't stop there he's got another
step
another step which is funny because he
he starts off by saying this is the only
thing you need to do but he does have
another step another step necessary in
this fight to smash the war racket is
limited a limited
placee
plebiscite sorry plebiscite which is a
plebiscite is is a direct vote like it's
just a vote plebiscite
another step necessary in this war
in this fight to smash the war rocket is
the limited plebiscite to determine
whether a war should be declared a
plebiscite not of all the voters
but merely of those who would be called
upon to do the fighting and dying
there wouldn't be very much sense in
having a 76 year old president of a
munitions factory or the flat-footed
head of an international banking firm or
the cross-eyed manager of a
uniform manual manufacturing plant all
of whom see see visions of tremendous
profits in the event of war voting on
whether the nation should go to war or
not
they never would be called upon to
shoulder arms to sleep in the trench and
to be shot
only those who would be called upon to
risk their lives for country should have
the privilege of voting to determine
whether the nation should go to war
there is ample precedent for restricting
the voting to those affected many of our
states have restrictions on those
permitted to vote in most it is
necessary to be able to read and write
before you may vote in some you must own
property it would be a simple matter
each year for the men coming of military
age to register in their communities as
they did
in the draft during the world war and be
physically examined those who could pass
and who were there for to be
who would therefore be called upon to
bear arms in the event of a war would be
eligible to vote in a limited plebiscite
they should be the ones to have the
power to decide and not a congress
few of those
few of whose members are within the age
limit and fewer still of whom are in the
physical condition to bear arms only
those who must suffer should have the
right to vote
there you go and as i said in vietnam
that kind of worked
people said um not johnny
and he said there was one step that he's
introduced to here's the third one
a third step in this business of
smashing war racket is to make certain
that our military forces
are truly for forces for defense only at
each session of congress the question
whether a whether further naval
appropriations comes up
the swivel chair admirals of washington
and there are always a lot of them are
very adroit lobbyists and they are smart
they don't shout that we need a lot of
battleships
we need a lot of battleships to war on
this nation or that nation nation oh no
first of all they let it be known that
america is menaced by a great naval
power almost any day these admirals will
tell you the great fleet of this
supposed enemy will strike suddenly and
annihilate 125 million people just like
that then they begin to cry for a larger
navy for what to fight the enemy oh my
no oh no for defense purposes only
then incidentally they announced
maneuvers in the pacific for defense
uh-huh the pacific is a great big ocean
we have tremendous coastline on the
pacific will the maneuvers be off the
coast two or three hundred miles oh no
the maneuvers will be 2 000 yes perhaps
even 3 500 miles off the coast
the japanese a proud people of course
will be pleased beyond expression to see
the united states fleet so close to
nippon's shores even as pleased as would
be the residents of california where
they'd dimly discern through the morning
mist the japanese fleet playing at war
games off los angeles
the ships of our navy can be seen should
specifically limited by law should be
specifically limited by law to within
200 miles of our coastline had that been
the law of 1898 the maine never would
have gone to havana harbor she never
would have been blown up there never
would have been no war with spain with
the attendant loss of life 200 miles is
ample in the opinion of experts for
defense purposes
our nation cannot start offense an
offensive war if it is ships can't go
further than 200 miles off the coastline
planes might be permitted to go 500
miles from the coast for the purpose of
reconnaissance and the army should never
leave the territorial limits of our
nation to summarize
three steps must be taken to smash the
war rocket one we must take the profit
out of war two we must permit the youth
of the land who would bear arms to
decide whether or not there should be
war
and three we must limit our military
forces to home defense purposes
again
um
not a great strategic plan to sit back
and like just stay in your own ao
you want to project power a little bit
you have to piss people off
but you definitely want to project some
power out there
what are you writing down dave
i'm just summarizing what he said i'm
just trying
i'm spending this all this time
just trying to appreciate what he's
saying because obviously and i'm gonna
wait you know i know there's a couple
more things to read here i'm gonna i'm
gonna wait to the conclusion but
i spent a lot of time in my own brain
saying i hear what you're saying i hear
what you're saying
well this is a but there's a yeah well
this is the thing that we have to do
that's like what the whole start of this
thing hey hey listen man we just spent a
trillion dollars totally man in a
20-year war
and when we got there the taliban was in
control of whatever percentage of the of
the country
and now we left and they're now going to
control 100 percent of the country
totally we spend a trillion dollars we
have thousands of
lost lives we have thousands more
wounded
maimed for life
yeah and and and
you have to at least open your mind and
say okay what's this guy talking about
yeah what was he talking about because
like you said this isn't some armchair
quarterback
this is a guy that fought
chapter five to hell with war
um
i am not as full to believe that war is
a thing of the past i know the people do
not want war but there is no use in
saying we cannot be pushed into another
war
looking back woodrow wilson was
realistic re-elected president in 1916
on a platform that he had quote kept us
out of war and quote and on the implied
promise that he would quote keep us out
of war
yet five months later he asked congress
to declare war on germany in that
five-month interval the people had not
been asked whether they had changed
their minds the four million young men
who put on uniforms and marched or
sailed away were not asked whether they
wanted to go forth and to suffer and die
then what caused our government to
change its mind so suddenly
money
an allied commission it may be recalled
came over shortly before the war
declaration and called on the president
the president summoned a group of
advisers the head of the commission
spoke stripped of its diplomatic
language this is what he told the
president and his group
there's no use in kidding ourselves any
longer
the cause of the allies is lost we now
owe you american bankers american
munition banker makers american
manufacturers american speculators
american exporters
five or six billion dollars
if we lose
and without the help of the united
states we will use
we england france italy
cannot pay back this money and germany
won't so
end quote
had secrecy been outlawed as far as war
negotiations were concerned and had the
press been invited to be present at that
conference or had the radio been
available to broadcast the precedings
america never would have entered the
world war
but this conference like all war
discussions was shouted in utmost
secrecy
when our boys were sent off to war they
were told it was a quote war to make the
world safe for democracy and a war to
end all wars
well 18 years after the world has less
of democracy than it had
besides what business is it of ours
whether russia or germany or england or
france or italy or austria live under
democracies or monarchies
whether they are fascists or communists
our problem is to to preserve our own
democracy
and very little if anything has been
accomplished to assure us that the world
war was really the war to end all wars
yes we have disarmament conferences and
limitations of arms conferences they
don't mean a thing
one has just failed the results of
another have been nullified
we send our professional soldiers and
sailors and our politicians and our
diplomats to these conferences and what
happens
the professional soldiers and sailors
don't want to disarm
no admiral wants to be without a ship no
general wants to be without a command
both mean men
both mean men without jobs they are not
for disarmament
they cannot be for limitations of arms
and at all these conferences lurking in
the background but all powerful just the
same are the sinister agents who profit
by war
they see to it that these conferences do
not disarm or seriously limit armaments
the chief aim of any power at any of
these conferences has not been to
achieve disarmament
to prevent war but rather to get more
armament for itself
and less for any potential flow foe
i
i remember having this thought when you
and i were in the battle of ramadi
and that thought was
how freaking awesome
the u.s military was
and how much of that awesomeness relied
on these individual human beings
that were making things happen
because when you look at
the operations that were taking place
when you look at the effort that was put
forth
it was
literally
platoon commanders company commanders
battalion commanders brigade commander
that was that was through force of will
making things happen
making things happen you could if if if
the brigade commander
didn't really care and just wanted to
kind of do a deployment get it under his
belt and just like uh yeah i did my
deployment
if he didn't care
if he didn't want to do good
we wouldn't have done anything yeah
right the battalion commander that's
going to push into an area of operations
that hasn't been pushed
there is individual effort
and here's what's scary
is
look in the battle of ramadi we were
trying to
we're trying to stabilize and secure the
city of ramadi
if there's no goal like that a clearly
defined goal and you have people that
are
trying to do make their best individual
effort to make their mark to leave their
mark to do something to get a good fit
rep
what are you going to do
you're going to say well
we're going to do this we're going to do
that we're going to expand we're going
to grow more i need more people
this idea that there's no real competing
competing um
asset or competing competing uh
perspective of someone saying hey wait a
second
what are you actually doing over there
i mean if let's say
you went you were you were in the marine
corps
and you were supposed to train iraqi
soldiers
and
i do turn over with you and you say yup
hey jocko we trained 100 iraqi soldiers
and i go that's great how many iraqi
soldiers do you think i'm going to train
how many think 101 at least 101 at least
101 yeah i'm gonna do more than you
totally
i'm gonna do more new i remember this is
back in the day i remember going out on
a
workups with the with the fleet
and you could see
i did a work up with the fleet that was
i wasn't i wasn't embarked but we did
some work with the marines
then my next deployment i did a full
workup with the marines then the next
one i did another full workup with the
marines so i did basically saw three
workups in a row with the marines and
each one of them was a little bit more
each workup was a little bit more sure
hey oh yeah you guys did you guys did
four amphibious landings oh yeah i'm
gonna do five we did five yeah oh what
about the next one with the next guys
doing six
this is real yeah
i had similar experience and even in
training uh you know
classic
yeah
a hundred percent 100
so when you get so that that just
reminds me of what we're talking about
here which is no admiral goes you know
what i think we need less ships
the amount of admirals that say that is
zero total the amount of generals that
say i need less divisions i need less
brigades i need less battalions the
number of generals that say that is zero
or you know sure are there some i'm sure
there are but the vast majority and
those those few that say well i think we
need less ships he's not getting he's
definitely not getting promoted he's not
gonna be the cno yeah he's definitely
not gonna be the cno hey i'm the guy
that downsized the navy promote me it's
not happening right it's not happening
hey i got us less brigades less combat
brigades good job yeah let's promote you
no one says that
so you have this self-fulfilling
prophecy and this self-licking ice cream
cone which is a term i understand what
it means but i'm not exactly sure
you know where it came from right but
that's what you have right is we want to
have more and that's exactly what he's
talking about here
there was no one
there was very few people
that would come back and say hey uh yeah
the iraqi soldiers we had to do it in
ramadi we had to say these guys are not
ready yet
because it was it was so obvious what
would happen if we just sent them out on
their own and they tried i mean remember
they turned over like some of the
checkpoints like two nine or five and
uh they turned it over and and two days
later the insurgents hit it and overrun
it uh ecp3 down there by on the bridge
same thing turned it over to the iraqis
hey these guys are ready you know it's
like actually no they weren't ready and
they got annihilated
so there wasn't really the the
opportunity for us to be like well yeah
the iraqi troops that we are trained are
now 100
what they call it what they call it
they're ready for unilateral operations
right
i didn't send up a message saying yep
our iraqis that we've been training for
six months are now ready for unilateral
operations even though that was what
everybody wanted us to say but we
couldn't say it there because you would
find out on their first operation that
there is no possible way they were ready
but if we would have been a more
permissive environment the pressure to
say
yeah hey they can conduct unilateral and
unilateral operations the pressure would
have been so great because otherwise be
like hey jocko the last the last task
unit commander that's out here has you
know he trained up four platoon special
mission unit elements that are now that
were now ready to perform unilateral
operations what did you do
i'd be like well actually i don't think
those four are even capable and we
should downgrade them
well what's wrong with you jocko the
last task unit commander was able to is
why couldn't you do that
so you have felt that pressure and a lot
of times people break to that pressure i
mean obviously i think that happened a
lot in afghanistan
yeah hey we trained these guys for six
months
and who says yeah we train somebody for
six months they're not capable we train
them for a year they're not capable it's
difficult it's a difficult
thing to do it's also difficult to
assess
so i think you get this that's what he's
talking about here there's no no admiral
wants to be without a ship no general
wants to be out of command
so what do they do they want more
there's only one way back to the book
there's only one way to disarm any
semblance of practicability
that is for all nations to get together
and scrap every ship every gun every
rifle every tank every warplane even
this if it were possible would not be
enough the next war according to experts
will not be fought with battleships not
by artillery not with rifles and not
with machine guns but it will be fought
with deadly chemicals and gases
secretly each nation is studying and
perfecting newer and ghastlier means of
annihilating its full its foes wholesale
yes ships will continue to be built for
the shipbuilders must make their profits
and guns will still be manufactured
manufactured and powder and rifles will
be made for the munitions makers must
make their huge profits
and the soldiers
of course must wear uniforms for the
manufacturer must make their war profits
too
but victory or defeat will be determined
by the skill and ingenuity of our
scientists
if we put them to work making poison gas
and more and more fiendish mechanical
and explosive instruments of destruction
they will have no time for the
constructive job of building greater
prosperity for all peoples
by putting them to this useful job we
can all make more money out of peace
than we can out of war
even the munitions makers so i say
to hell with war
and that's the end of it um
again you know he's he's in the end you
know kind of uh got the fantasy got the
fantasy argument of hey can't we just
have people working on
good
to have the scientists working on good
stuff instead of evil stuff and like
yeah cool like so it's it's such an
extreme argument that people go oh he's
he's just crazy right and let's throw
this whole book out
um
but
if we're to actually listen to what he's
saying and maybe put some of it in the
crazy pot
and
put some of it in the just factual pot
and then some of it is debatable like
okay what does that actually mean how
does that apply today
i think it's
i think it's very important for us to do
that
i i was recently on
russell brand's podcast
and the thing is it's behind a pay wall
is that right yes sir okay a firewall
it's behind the paywall
and so russell brand if you don't know
who he is he's uh a guy from england
super nice guy
very funny guy he's he's originally a
comedian kind of a movie comedian yeah
kind of and a performer as well so he
does aka aldis snow
what's this now all this snow that's his
other alias oh really yeah that's like
his character you know and what's that
guy supposed to be like a singer
really yeah get him to the greek uh
forgetting sarah
marshall look into it
that's who russell brand is okay he's a
man so it was he he's an actor too yes
sir
super nice guy
um and
he asked me to be on his podcast and it
was pretty it's pretty cool because he
started off the podcast
he was saying like he was being real
complimentary of me and like and and and
just being nice you know this guy
you know he he thanked me for my service
and and
you know he he he said i did great bunch
of great stuff and and real
complimentary nice and and i kind of
said hey man i appreciate it i said bro
i'm not like
this
i'm not a rare
uh
hero from the military i said i had a
kind of average career
um and then he goes well you know i just
wanted to say that because i want you to
know that i respect the military but
because i want to set that up properly
because i also have like some issues and
i'm going to probably go
he didn't use the term hard in the paint
because he's from england but he
basically meant i'm gonna go hard in the
paint
on some topics and then i said well hey
you should then know that
even though i spent my adult life in the
military i was also like a hardcore kid
growing up listening to heavy metal
playing in bands i'm a rebellious kid i
listen to punk rock and heavy metal and
so you should just know that too that
even though i because he he also
mentioned that he's like as i look like
a hippie and i was like because i know i
look like a the most military human
that you could imagine that's true yeah
that i also know that you know you
should know that i'm kind of a rebel and
that as well and so then we had a little
laughing
um
so so eventually you know we get to we
start having the conversation and then
he posed this kind of
two questions
and they were somehow paired up
or they were somehow there was like a
semicolon between them
meaning they were attached they weren't
quite separate but they were still
attached but they were they were a
little bit separate so the one of them
was like isn't
war
driven by the profitability of the
military-industrial complex that was
kind of questionable number one and then
similar question isn't capitalism
and and businesses and corporations
aren't they simply driven by the
profitability
for the rich owners and shareholders
so that was kind of the question aren't
these two major forces in the world the
military and the corporate world aren't
they just driven
by
greed essentially
and then i answered him and i you know
my answer was well
russell
the answer is yes
and
i think i think he was a little bit
taken aback by that
answer but
the fact of the matter is it's true that
profits certainly drive corporations
to do things
to to make products
and defense companies certainly get rich
during wars as we just heard from
smedley butler
those are totally true
totally true
and
just like smedley butler like you and i
were saying dave that that's like one
part of the argument that's not the only
driver
that's not the only driver
and
i mean for the corporate example
i've worked with hundreds of companies
and dave you've worked with hundreds
companies and the companies make money
they make a lot of money
and they are certainly driven by profits
in some way but they're also making
products that people want and they're
making products that people need and
they're employing people
and they're making products that make
people's lives better
that's what's happening
in in the vast majority of cases no
better example than
medical device companies pharmaceutical
companies and i've worked with scores of
medical device companies i've worked
with scores of pharmaceutical companies
over the last decade
and
some of those companies that i've worked
with that you've worked with dave some
of those companies make hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars in
profit billions of dollars in profit
and so you could say to yourself well
that's what's driving them just to want
to make money but
i have also seen and met
their patients along the way
you go to event and they got a a man or
a woman or a ch a child a little boy or
a little girl and the only reason that
that
child is still alive
is because of this device that that
company makes or this drug that this
company makes
that's that's
that's why they are on stage they will
present
and they'll get these people up there
and say thank you and those patients who
are only alive because of these
companies are grateful to be alive and
they are overjoyed
that those
capitalist doctors were greedy enough
right to take the risk and invest money
and push hard and toil and do the work
to create products that actually saved
people's lives
and the same thing
the same thing can be said for war
the same thing can be said for war and
i have participated in wars that made
some defense companies tons of money
you know i said i said this russell
brand something along the lines of like
listen i could be talking to my platoon
and say all right guys
here's what's going on tonight we're
going to go out we're going to risk our
lives and i just want to let you know
that every round that you fire
is going to put 12 cents into the
pockets of the wartime profiteers
right and that would actually be true
because that is true
those those rounds cost money and those
defense companies make money from those
things
but i also know what happens on the
ground dave you know what happens on the
ground
i know i know that we help people
the people on the ground
i know that we killed evil
terrorists and insurgents that
systematically tortured and raped and
murdered the innocent local populace
i know that we did that
i know that we were able to protect
children from these insurgents from
these terrorists i know we were able to
protect families i know that those
families wanted these insurgents out of
their city and out of their country
and so while there were defense
companies certainly making money there
was a simultaneous
good that was taking place
then we took lives but we also saved
lives and that's the truth
enriching
global corporations and enriching the
military-industrial complex
that enrichment certainly influences
behaviors right it influences someone
that's making a weapon system to try and
make their weapon system better
to try and make better body armor
there's a there's someone right now as
we speak that is trying to make better
body armor and part of the reason
they're trying to make it is to protect
the american soldier but
guess what they got a mortgage to pay
and they want to make better better body
armor because they want to make more
money and if they can make better body
armor then the us government goes wow
that's lighter it's stronger it
provides more protection we're gonna buy
it
it's not that the person is just
thinking about money
but the money the the the two
goals are aligned there's a simultaneous
drive
that is that is moving
behavior in the right direction and
often times like i just use that example
body armor they're aligned
with this company out there
acme body armor they want to make best
body armor
and they want to make it do they want to
protect americans yes they do do they
want to make money yes they do so i have
no problem with that
if they're aligned it works out
perfectly
here's the problem
the problem is if they're out of
alignment
that's where it can become awful and
that's what we need to watch out for
what is the driving force behind going
to war
are we going to works is the right thing
to do are we going to war for benevolent
reasons
are we positive that it will have a a
positive impact
that will offset the natural negative
impacts of war because when you go on a
war there's going to be negative impacts
people are going to die people are going
to get wounded
and is the positive impact going to
offset that negative impact is it going
to help
stability
in the world is there a strategic
benefit for us as america
if we're going to war for those reasons
because there's going to be a strategic
advantage because it protects our
national security because it's going to
be truly good for the people on the
ground that need protection that need
help to get out from a tyrannical
a tyrannical regime or an evil regime
and there are evil regimes
and if you don't think there's evil
regimes you're wrong
because there's people in the world
there's regimes in the world that will
systematically rape little kids
so if we're going to war
for those reasons
okay
it's we can consider it
if the primary driver of going to war is
to make money if it's the profit if it's
to sell more guns and bombs
if it's not going to stabilize the world
if it doesn't help us protect our
national security
if it's going to be a strategic defeat
then we're wrong and and can there be
alignment by these two drivers yes they
absolutely can
i don't mind i don't mind someone making
great body armor making money off i
don't make i don't mind somebody making
a great weapon system that makes a bunch
of money
and it helps us win a war i have no
problem with that at all
but if these things aren't aligned and
we're fighting for money or we're
fighting for profit and we're not
getting positive impact and we're not
getting strategic benefit
well then we need to listen to major
general smedley butler and say to hell
with what
that's what i'm thinking dave
um
i'm with you
i was thinking of a story as you as you
said that i i don't even remember why i
was in the pentagon but i was in the
pentagon for something
and it was
maybe like i was just taking over
this f-35 job and had to go meet
somebody in the pentagon whatever dave
came up to the pentagon and talked to
some general i literally walked through
the halls of the pentagon and i run into
who is an old battalion commander that i
work with who is now i happen to be a
one star just literally walked into him
in a in a waiting room of some office
somewhere waiting for some meeting and
we bumped into each other and he was
there with a couple people from a
company in industry so civilians in the
industry
and he was there
to show the technology of a helmet that
they designed to stop a 762 caliber
sniper rifle a helmet light enough but
strong enough to stop a sniper rifle
and
for those of you who are listening that
don't know the story of and i've talked
in general terms about my radio operator
chris leon who was on my team the first
angle marine killed my radio operator
was killed in ramadi the first angle
marine killed in iraq was my ready
operator was shot and killed by a sniper
that pierced his helmet went right
through the temple of his helmet and
killed him
was i
on board with this company
making profit making money off the
american taxpayer to design a helmet
that would somehow
have prevented what happened
or at least can prevent what might
happen in the future yes i'm on board
that plan i'm on board with that plan
and i support that plan and i want that
plan to not only make them money
but make enough money to continue to
build even better technology grow their
company and be a positive force for
whatever may happen so i am
i am totally on board with that idea and
this idea of alignment
and while
where i struggled especially towards the
end listening to him talk you reading
his words was
i think a trap that is so easy to fall
into is that we describe it as the
government or industry or the military
one of the things that i've learned
in in our current job is that these are
actually people they're people the the
military is just people and generals and
admirals are regular people and you know
what there are some really good ones and
there are some not so good ones
and
people in the government i know
classmates of mine that are that work in
the government and you know what they
try to do most of the time every day
the right thing they try to do the right
thing do they always do the right thing
no are there forces at play that make it
difficult of course
but when you fall into this trap of like
oh it's the government
it's really easy to create a narrative
by which their only goal
is to somehow
whether it's lying their pockets or
whatever that might be is we lose sight
of the fact that most of the mechanics
that are going on inside industry these
companies we work with
are regular people trying to do the
right thing even for the most part of my
experience at the highest levels we work
with ceos of multi-billion dollar
companies
and what you get to know is that for the
most part for the most part
they're people trying to do the right
thing are they trying to make money yes
because for a whole host of good reasons
they want to pay their bills they want
to pay their people they want to grow
they want to expand they want to build
brighter products that are safer they
can reach more all these things
and i'm not
naive
and i don't want people to think the
exact opposite was like everybody's just
altruistic in it for the for the big no
that's not the case but there's a trap
that we can fall into which was
there's this this thing
the industry well if it's just the
industry then yeah it's easy to paint
them as as this
this
thing that's not a real thing it's not a
person it's not a human being and what
this thing wants is to just
soak up dollar bills
or
waste human life to get to their end
state with no regard for that and and
that is a a that is a trap that
i think it's easy to fall into and you
can hear his words like hey hang on a
second
just
hang on
who is
this company
who are these
industries or governments or whatever
these things we're talking about
most of the time most of the time there
are people trying to do the right thing
that's what they are most of the time
yeah uh you know what survivor biases
yes
yeah do you know what it is i think so
it's like um
if you go out and you talk to 10 people
that started companies
and you say you know hey how hard was it
to start your company they're all like
yeah it was pretty easy man you know i
got it going you're not talking to the
90 other people that failed so you get
this survivor bias we at echelon front
probably have a little bit of echelon
front bias which is we mo the companies
that we work with
they've read extreme ownership they're
in the game they listen to podcasts like
these these are companies that have a
a good sort of fundamental value system
so
we we kind of have a little bit of that
bias because you're right the amount of
companies that we've worked with where
i've said wow
this guy is going to put this product
out there that's harmful or this guy or
this woman is making a decision that's
going to cause their employees to suffer
it doesn't happen
now are the companies like that yes
there are and and but i would tell you
same thing even though even with even if
you take into account the ef bias the
echelon front bias which is that most
people that we work with have a good
value system even with that accounted
for most companies
these days you have to have a good value
system you have to be doing the right
thing because there's just too much
information out there
and a damn yelp review i mean on the
like the the base level hey if you run a
restaurant and you treat your employees
or your customers bad a yelp review now
you go big and you run into you know the
wall street journal is doing an expose
on what you did to maximize profits
while you hurt your
you know your your employees or your
clients or whatever so
so the
even in cases where you have people that
might not be the most altruistic people
yeah the reality of modern technology
keeps on keeps the vast majority of them
in check yes so that's true the other
thing is look there's going to be these
two these two things they create a nice
positive natural tension
that's what we want we want to have
someone saying like hey yeah if you guys
go to war we want you have the best gear
that's good and the other the the the
business should be saying hey if we want
you to go to war we want you have the
best gear and the general should be
saying yeah we don't want to go to war
but if we do we want the best gear
there's a little tension these guys
might want to go to war more these guys
might not but
there there should be a natural tension
and i think what we have to watch out
for is when there's no
when people lose that when there's no
tension when there's no one saying hey
you know you know you know i just want
you to think about something if we go to
war it's johnny over here that's going
to get killed that's going to lose his
legs whatever the case may be that's
what we never that's what we need to
make sure people think about i know this
goes back to
one of the f actually i think it might
have been the first like ever thing that
i got recorded
saying
was
when we did the the war fighters
thing for the history channel about mark
lee and i've repeated this on a bunch of
occasions
how do you know when it's time to go to
war
and the the it's time when you are
willing you when you are willing you
have the will but it's the will to die
and it's the will to kill and that's
what's going to happen your war so you
need to put that overlay on this yeah
and if you ever forget about that
overlay that you think well you know
this is worth it because it's gonna be
beneficial okay oh cool it's gonna be
beneficial to the people there do you
know that we're gonna kill some of the
people there not just the enemy but some
of the people that are there are going
to die because of us and we're going to
have our own people killed
that's what we need to think about we
can never lose that tension
and and i think that that tension does
get lost i think that the people that
that hold up their hand say hello wait a
second
what are we doing here and and part of
the reason is because
what is it there's a saying
old men want to go to war and
young men do too i mean you know it's
that's the thing you survey freaking 19
year old kids that are in the marine
corps and you ask them how many people
how many you want to go to war
there's a big percentage that's coming
through in the affirmative
and that's the coolest part about the
comment about that tension which is i
mean that's actually the tension that
you want is
i want i actually want marines that want
to go to 100 that's what i want i want
reasons i want to go to war and do i
love the idea of world peace yes i love
that idea i love that idea
that idea is not going to happen today
or tomorrow it's not going to happen
and
is as much as i love the fantasy of this
the the simple things we need to do to
to achieve that
the the the tension is you know with
that reality too is that hey
not only is that
not likely there are people that
actively do not want that actively do
not want that and you know he i was he
was talking about he you know the next
step is we're gonna see war uh with
chemicals and and he was sort of
foreshadowing what then and he was
correct obviously you know we we know
that there was you know some of those
things he saw that at world war ii with
chemical warfare and he was
foreshadowing this ever-growing capacity
for people to wage war against each
other in these awful awful ways well
you know you could get rid of all the
weapons in the world and there's people
waging war with computers now
so this this this
persistence of the reality
with some of the nefarious things and
the profiteers that might be out there
there's a reality out there that we also
need to accept and face and i want to be
around people that want to do that
i want to be around those people and i
want marines
i want marines
that have that exact same feeling and
yes do you want to manage that and
temper that and guide that and shape it
yes all those things
but i want to be around those people and
i think that that tension that you
talked about that natural tension
because those two things exist in the
world
and to pretend like they don't is
is not a good plan yeah i don't know
what the percentage of people uh
let's say you let's say you did what
they said if you take the young men that
are going to have to go to war and they
get to vote
i almost feel i almost don't feel super
comfortable with that because i think a
lot of them would be like oh yeah it's
on here's my chance yeah it's on but but
i'm not sure that's also my own warped
that's sort of the jocko bias which is i
think everyone's kind of thinks like me
which i know it's not true there's also
a chance that i'm wrong and a bunch of
people would say no matter what was
happening in the world they'd be like no
we're not going to war right you know
what i mean so you got to have somebody
with a detached perspective yeah that's
actually saying you know what now is not
the time to go to war or a detached
perspective and say hey we're looking at
this whole thing we see
nazis we see them running rough shot all
over we need to do something about this
and you described it again i i
the you know whether you call it the
tension or or this idea hey when you've
got some skin in the game when it's not
johnny it's your johnny
when you're talking about who's going to
war
yeah i love that idea of
oh
you talking about me now okay hang on
let me let me put some thought into it
because in the end the answer actually
might still be yeah i'm going to send my
son off to war
but i'm certainly going to think about
it a lot harder the closer it is to me
and i mean that's been the challenge in
society forever which was do we want to
insulate our people for more yeah we do
i want i want to insulate america from
war and you could look at we talked
about afghanistan
are there some good things that come out
of that
yeah absolutely and if you insulate them
so much if you if you remove them so
much that they don't even understand
what really is happening those decisions
actually aren't the best decisions
because
what do they care right yeah sure it's a
great idea go go go to war
um
doesn't affect me at all i don't want a
society that has no no impact on that
either and even inside that you talk
about that tension of i want to keep
[Music]
i want to separate us from that as much
as possible but if not but not so much
they don't understand what it actually
what that really means to send somebody
off to war we were just talking an hour
ago when these people went to world war
one didn't even know what they were
doing they even know what it meant to
send someone to war and there's just no
way
yeah there's some some great things with
technology and
if you're doing something for the wrong
reason it's pretty it's it's much harder
to hide that now than it ever used to be
if your
industrial plan or your company plan is
really nefarious you're you're running
the risk of getting found out there's
just too much information that's free
out there it's really hard to keep those
secrets anymore but sending somebody off
to world war one do you think anybody
really knew what that meant
no no and do i do you think they should
know a little bit yeah i see his point
it's your kid going you might think
twice before you you send him but just
like you said too there are actually
times so you're gonna say yeah because
the alternative
that's not acceptable
well definitely um i think the lesson
here is keep your minds open
and listen
and
try and understand these various
perspectives that are out there
because i bet there's a bunch of people
that
hear this and they go well that guy was
a traitor or whatever they're gonna say
yeah
or say hell yeah it's it's just that's
what makes it so interesting because you
can't call a guy that did what he did in
his life a traitor
and what we should actually do
is listen
that's what we should do with an open
mind with an open mind goes a long way
yeah
with that
echo charles yes sir so we're trying to
keep our minds open but we're also
trying to keep our mind sharp yes sir
keep the sharp minds got to keep the the
vessel
that the mind is contained in got to
keep that kind of up and running sure
concur
the brain
well yeah no well the brain the brain is
in the
body sure
the skull more specifically more
specifically yup see look at you i'm
trying
oh very creative to my comments there
was there was a there was a part in
there where he was he was kind of going
hard you know exposing all these
prophets and all this stuff and it makes
sense man so and you can kind of get a
taste of his emotional state right it
makes sense but also you got to say hey
man if i was having to fight the
freaking nazis how happy am i that i
have some american steel manufacturer
that is staying awake 24 hours a day you
ever seen that when they used to build
those liberty ships you know what i'm
talking about dave
these big liberty ships that were used
to transport stuff back across back and
forth across the atlantic ocean they
were making them in a day
a freaking whole ship bro this is
impossible and america was doing it in a
day now if i was over there on the front
lines and i needed some more ammunition
i would be so damn happy and i would be
more than happy that people are making a
bunch of money did the profits get a
little bit extreme
maybe they got a little extreme yeah so
in in that that's kind of the point
there where
you can kind of he goes hard in like
both directions and you're like oh man i
see i especially when he's talking about
the waist you know like the ships that
don't even run and it's like no we're
still paying the bill and it's like and
then meanwhile you know from his
perspective he sees all the all the
downside of war right hardcore and then
he kind of sees and he looks and he sees
all these numbers all these dollar signs
that go to other people or whatever who
are making shitty ships and all this
stuff oh man i get it but he went a
little bit too hard in a bun
even in these little subtle ways extreme
extreme so he goes makes you shut him
out about that a little bit yes and
and i was trying to stay like with you
guys were like okay get it no no maybe
not man but there was a party he was
talking about the boots right he was
like oh they made all these boots and
like all this stuff or whatever and i'm
so thinking wait that's the we kind of
need those boots
but we only had four million soldiers
and we bought 25 million boots yes okay
and then that part it's like okay yes as
far as the waste goes 100 that's gonna
apply across the board um and then he he
went on to even add like oh those were
good boots yeah yeah yeah i was like
yeah we need those boots yeah but we
wasted of course of course we don't need
the waste that's true same thing with
the ships and all that stuff but so you
could tell like all you got to do is
kind of detach from like that very
specific perspective just a little bit
and you're like okay this guy might not
be getting it you know in certain ways
well i i don't think that's a great
example because you can also say hey he
gets it these are boots we need boots
they're good boots they're probably
lasting for a long time we didn't need
25 million pairs bro
yeah that's true
yeah so he he's getting it where he
loses it is just saying that that's the
only reason that they're doing anything
right and that's what i mean where and
because that's it seemed like it put it
this way it seemed like he was going
hard in that direction it's like that's
what he kind of wanted you to think yeah
it's it also shows you that
the
you know you have a government
organization that's running things
and it's not your money yeah yeah you're
gonna get fraud waste and abuse yeah
that means a big way that's why
that's why it's usually better
to have a little bit less government
control over things yeah that's so to
keep things as decentralized as possible
and i know i covered a little bit of
uh of uh thomas saul's book
i think i don't even know if i even got
to it it was i don't think you were on
the podcast was with jordan peterson but
he got this little section where he just
talks about how freaking hard it is to
like control price you just
you can't you can't do it you can't
control price
has to do with the pelts of some animal
there's a worth a certain amount
and then he goes through how hard it is
to control the price and then he says
and by the way there's
whatever 1.2 billion
products or line items that you need to
control the price of it's impossible
you got to let the free market work a
little bit
and that's where you run into problems
where you have the free market brush up
against the government
the government
uh checkbook yeah and they're like yeah
we can make you probably need 25 million
boots how many soldiers you got
four million
they need yeah sign here
so
yeah that's true huh cause you know like
when you get with the old thing the
irresponsible person with the crew when
they first get a credit card kind of
feels like oh it's not my money right so
then they overspend they can't pay that
kind of stuff so it's like like it makes
sense that phenomenon
does make sense people will spend their
other people's money like crazy yeah
they do it all the time that's what the
government does the government spends
other people's money all the time
you know
do we need to spend some money yeah yeah
but if you looked at it from like a
household perspective if this if this
either this state we're in california or
this country
if you looked at it from that standpoint
of hey our budget you know we make
hey look here's here's hey you know hey
darling wife we make
five thousand dollars a month
that's how much income we bring in um
we're gonna buy a car that's gonna cost
us two thousand dollars a month and
we're gonna rent a
uh uh an apartment that's gonna cost us
four thousand dollars a month
and then we're gonna go out to eat every
night
that total is gonna be seven thousand
dollars a month
you can figure out real quick like oh
i'm in the hole this is the credit card
problem yeah so but if it's not our
money yeah we're kind of like hey we'll
go into debt a little bit it's all good
watch out man
yeah
just gotta be careful with this stuff
yeah all right what do we got so
speaking of be being careful i like it
we gotta be careful with what we put in
our bodies
especially on this path about this hard
dave burke
i'm saying it's hard it's not always
easy it's fun it can be fun from time to
time okay especially when you're
collecting those long-term gains see i'm
saying
capability cognitive enhancement smarts
all that stuff better decision making
too
either way when we're on this path we
want to stay healthy stay ahead of the
game health wise
dave i notice you're drinking the mango
discipline good choice
you could have drank the orange you
could have but i have a little bit of a
love hate relationship with the mango i
understand fully so discipline go that's
what this is that's what we're talking
about here it's a healthy healthy energy
drink
yep it's a big deal most times the
energy drink as we know them or as we
knew you know where i'm going to go with
this right now where are you going well
we were
talking earlier about the fact that hey
most companies are out there trying to
do the right thing
and guess what we have we have some
companies that are out there saying oh
you know what
if i can cut the cost of my product by a
little bit add some chemicals to it that
are a little bit cheaper
give people an addictive thing called
sugar
and they'll just buy more of it cool so
we got our example now we got some
nefarious companies
out there making poison and feeding it
to people it's kind of a spectrum to and
consider i'm not just saying necessarily
energy drinks or whatever but like in
general especially when it comes to
stuff that you eat or put in your body
whatever
because you're dealing with two
different forces there yeah you know
what bothers me about that though is
this like
is the attitude like yeah but that's
what people want
right that's what i'm saying there's two
different forces and that's not a good
that that's that's what people want that
doesn't mean you can't
just make adjustments to give them what
they want and not give them poison hey
some people want crack some people
aren't straight up some people want
vodka straight up mainstream some people
want
is vodka good
it's about good good no
kind of hard to make that argument on
you know on many many levels either way
i dig what you're saying but guess what
we don't have to worry about that kind
of stuff anymore we are not a nefarious
company negative we are making the clean
the clean energy drinking energy drink
both uh win-win upside short-term upside
long-term in many ways too by the way
there's electrolytes in this one yeah
yeah
imagine just being saying oh yeah you
want to try something
all upside oh
how often do you get that in life yeah
hey you hear something all upside
yeah and as far as like the mango flavor
it's like really upside yeah especially
okay insane
as compared to other flavors which is
just normal upside which i understand of
course
either way
if you want if you want to take part in
this energy drink rather than the
poisonous snacks i'm starting to go down
the path now now we're talking about
nefarious companies i'm going straight
to the clothing manufacturer's necks
that are out there cutting the corners
and saying oh we'll just get this made
in china we got slave labor over there
yeah we got the uyghurs over there in
actual slave labor camps making you're
making your shorts
how's that feel
doesn't it feel good no
i don't feel good about it i don't feel
good about either that's why you know
what i don't get i don't get shorts that
are made in china
yeah i dig it man i dig it but back to
the energy drinks okay you want to stick
with those for mental and physical
enhancements
enhancer capability also
uh you can get stuff to to take you out
of any kind of roadblocks or speed bumps
in recovery
we got protein we got stuff for your
joints
we got
stuff for you immunity
we also got protein but you could
actually just call it dessert yes
another one of those
i almost had an emergency the other day
i thought i ran out of peanut butter
yeah wait peanut butter flavored milk
peanut butter peanut butter flavored
milk yeah but then it was in the back of
the caps
but i was like speaking of crack yeah i
look like a crack crack cocaine addict
yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was one of my daughters just
like went ham on the peanut butter yeah
makes sense yeah and it was just like
downtown i got you know half a scoop
which is not going to get you through
the moment
right you uh you mentioned your daughter
and they're older your kids are older
i'm kind of young where i play tricks on
them
where they're not tricks it's a strategy
you see i'm saying so i don't give them
mulk when they want it
i said i mean one it's almost it's like
a reward yeah
you see what i'm saying it creates that
that demand
so when they when they hit it boom
that's the standard of the standard
payoff of the desserts i'm saying
meanwhile they're getting the the tail
and the benefits
yeah that's a good idea i'm out of
peanut butter by the way b little's on
the case that's you with the long war
going i'm over here trying that's for
sure all right we got a bunch of stuff
where do we get this stuff jacqua
fuel.com also okay the the energy drinks
you can get at wawa you can get it at
vitamin shop you can get a
jockofield.com
um the rest of stuff mostly
jockofield.com and vitamin chocolate
yeah hey just real quick if you want it
delivered if you don't want to run out
of peanut butter milk or whatever else
if you don't want to run out jordan if
you subscribe to it shipping is free
so that's our way of competing with some
other large corporations that may not be
as benevolent
the with you
yeah it's a good move right there
subscribe
also origin usa this is where you can
get american-made stuff you said it you
mentioned it yeah like sometimes hey
some places some some of the clothes
that that some of the people
where
it's made with slave labor straight up
and varying levels of slave slave labor
too you can go deep in that rabbit hole
and find out some stuff right you're not
yeah you can go on whatever those other
youtube channels are that you were
talking about you can watch you know
little kids getting beaten because they
didn't produce enough freaking pairs of
shorts yeah bruh
yeah you can go deep for sure but
without depressing anymore like the
factories where they got nets around
them so when the people try and kill
themselves they
hit the net and then they drag them back
in and put them back in front of the
sewing machine again
you know what i'm saying yeah that was
really scary i didn't know that that was
real
yeah that but that's a scary thing to
consider like that's how common it is
that they have a straight up sop like a
little protocol and they play oh yeah
this is just just to prevent the people
from from actually dying when they try
to commit suicide so that's why we want
another day and a half yeah
we need that labor you see what i'm
saying for this for
clothes our
we're we're not down with that no we're
not that down with that so all this
stuff is a made in america be made in
america by people who want to make this
this stuff they're so fired up like
brett just grab one person from there
okay so you can and you can see this on
their youtube channel by the way but you
see the people making it their brother
they'll explain the whole thing to you
yeah they'll be like oh yeah this one is
this and this isn't that in fact i saw
one where they're saying hey i'm making
this for this very specific person i was
like damn
that's where i want to get my stuff from
for sure origin usa dot com that's true
made in america yep jiu-jitsu grown in
america yeah the seeds jiu-jitsu stuff
boots by the way we have we made we sold
the government 24 million pairs of boots
we haven't yet
but even if we did we wouldn't sell them
24 million
not necessarily if they don't need to
know especially because these boots are
going to last
yeah
so and you're going to look good too
let's face it let's face it
echo if you if echo ever goes into
combat he's going to be
that's key component
alpha
well
that that's something that does have
some value same same because i think a
lot of people we care about like at the
very least a little bit about what it
looks like it's insane i put on the
delta 68 it's not like i didn't look in
the mirror i was like it's not like i
was like sure they fit and then just
kind of walked out just i looked in the
mirror a little bit and in fact i
remember
when i red red-shirted in football
and we're warming up for the game you
know you can you can suit up for the
game when you're red shirt for football
and the coach said
he was like dang echo looks good in his
uniform he's not ready to play
but he looks good in his uniform well
that could be also a foreshadowing of
your tactical yeah your tactical
missions in life you might not be ready
to operate
you will look good yeah that's what i
felt when i put on the delta 68. yeah
i'm not ready for you know the the
mekong delta but i'm ready to wear this
stuff for sure 100 percent nonetheless
get all the origin usas good stuff
guilt-free stuff and
superior stuff yeah another win-win on
that one also chocolate is a store
called jacko store so you go to
jackalstore.com and that's where you can
represent hardcore
on the path discipline equals freedom
good
it's a good way to look at things
you're gonna watch that video yeah
that'll help a lot of us through some
some stuff man nonetheless you want to
represent that's where you can got some
other stuff on there some shorts some
hats some hoodies
women's stuff you heard me say that's
good thing for the first time were you
like oh this is good yeah i did you like
new at the moment
well if you remember how that video all
came about or whatever if you even want
to call it coming about
i had my camera in the corner and when i
was reading the notes like you know i'll
just go over the notes or whatever i was
like oh that one's gonna be a good one
so i i didn't even take out the camera
and set it up if you noticed if you
remember yeah i kind of i brought it out
of the corner and if you watch that
video if you look close you can see like
there's like my computer monitor kind of
obstructing like it wasn't set up it's
just like i just sort of started running
it because i thought oh yeah that's
looked good in the notes check you out
dude so just put some freaking music on
that [ __ ] and send it out
nonetheless you want to represent like i
said jackalstore.com
go there if you like something get
something also we have a subscription
thing too free shipping on this one as
well some new maybe
more creative designs on that one good
feedback on that one
check
yeah yeah see the short shot that says
check yep it's true
also you know uh there's a we have an
homage to the sea wolves on there
we've got a homage to another group that
we have grown very fond of that's all
i'm going to say right let me inspect
that thing
better let me inspect that thing before
we roll it out yeah please cause i gotta
oh you gotta have the ominous dominus
just to confirm all right there have
been errors made in the past i think we
don't need to bring them up right now
but there have been things that have
been
created without approval and they were
not correct all right well you know
that's the risk we all run but yes
you're correct and occasionally
occasionally you know look i'm i'm prone
to run things a little bit too
decentralized that's kind of what i do
yes but occasionally let's do a little
inspection to make sure we aren't
making mistakes that we don't want to
make what do we call a qa quality
quality assurance before you print the
shirt and send it to people you should
do that yeah i think you might be right
about that actually okay i understand
what you're saying no yes i remember i
remember did brick in the house actually
dave burke was a big part of that uh
rectification yeah okay yeah yeah when i
say a big part i mean the part so let's
let's just do a review this is what
we'll call it a review
hey uh subscribe to this podcast
wherever you subscribe to podcast we'll
also have jocko unraveling we have the
grounded podcast we're the warrior kid
podcast we also have jocko underground
where we are talking about
uh
let's see
closely related topics
we're answering q a so there's a special
way you can send your questions in
and so we're answering q a on there
and
it is also our
place to go in the event of
problems
problems you uh if we get banned or
whatever you're always like advertising
some stuff or whatever yeah you always
like gloss over they oh just do q a or
whatever
and a lot of those questions are like
that's like advice like if you want life
advice from jocko it's sort of that's
essentially its column i guess it is bro
it is and jocko willing life coach
jocko underground.com hell yeah yeah it
sounds funny when you say like that but
conceptually you know what's weird i
said that for the first time a long time
like before i even got out of the navy
because guys would come to me and be
like what's going on i'd be like doggo
like life coach oh yeah you know and i'd
say here's what you need to do bro amen
it's effective i'm telling you sometimes
like they'll ask these questions and
i'll be like oh yeah i'll read the
question or whatever and you think you
know you think you know what i'm going
to say well i a lot of times i do know
what you're going to say okay in general
but here's the thing here's what happens
sometimes where someone i'll read the
question and and i'll be like oh yeah
that's a unique question for like that
person you know it doesn't really apply
to me so it'd be interesting to hear
jocko's answer which i may or may not
know the answer you know as far as the
one he's going to give but then you
expand on this answer it's like wait a
second i can kind of use that right
there you see insane so it kind of like
it kind of affects your life even even
though the question's not like
necessarily just yours if you got
questions you want them answered do you
want to hear what we talk about on
that underground podcast go to
jockowunderground.com it costs eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month
that's how you're supporting that whole
thing
if you can't afford it it's cool we
still want you in the game email
assistance
jockowunderground.com we have a youtube
channel
you can subscribe to that also origin
usa has a cool youtube channel where
they're showing behind the scenes what's
going on psychological warfare is an
album that echo made i talked on it so
we made sure okay so we made it as a
little collaborative effort
i
came up with the things i wrote it i
then i did the words and then i said
them in a proper way and echo
collaborated by pressing record which
was cool yeah i do it so if you want to
get the psychological warfare you need a
little help getting through some moment
of weakness
we got you jocko life coach okay we got
you
uh if you want something to hang on your
walls go to flipsidecampus.com dakota
meyer
speaking of metal on of honor
dakota meyer without question um
earned that thing
and he's got a cool company made in
america flipsidecanvas.com making stuff
to hang on your wall
got a bunch of books final spin coming
out soon we don't even know what is it a
book is it a novel is it a poem is it
what do you call it dave you've read it
literature it's all those things i guess
i know what it says on the cover yeah
what does it say on the cover final spin
oh it says
yeah that's right
they have to call it something it's more
than that i know that for sure yeah
check
uh then we have
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
that's gonna answer all your questions
about leadership the code the evaluation
of protocols
you gotta know you gotta have a code you
gotta evaluate yourself you gotta follow
some protocols in life there you go we
wrote them for you me and dave burke
discipline because freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons
about face by hackworth
i wrote the forward to it extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
leif babin
echelon front we have a leadership
consultancy and what we do is we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com if you want to have us
engage with your company your business
or your team go to ashlandfront.com
that's also where you can find out what
about the live events that we do we do
the muster
big leadership
learning
session two days long next one up is in
uh vegas
las vegas october 28th and 29th we also
do field training exercise we run around
and do tactical missions and utilize the
principles of leadership
we do ef battlefield tour gettysburg
primarily we don't make you march there
but we do walk around there and and
learn those lessons
we have an online training course
because we we want to get this
information to as many people as
possible how do you do that how do you
scale that i can't be everywhere dave
can't be anywhere everywhere leif babin
can't be everywhere jp can't be
everywhere we can't just be everywhere
so what we did is we consolidated
information onto the extreme ownership
academy it's leadership courses we do
live sessions on there all the time if
you have a question you come there and
ask me go to extreme ownership.com for
that if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a charity organization that does all
kinds of great stuff for our military
members and our veterans if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want more
of my prolonged proclamations
or you need more of echo's derelict
decrees
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on the gram on facebook
echoes echo charles i am at jocko
willink where are you at dave david r
burke
david r burke i escaped the uh
the ridicule the ridicule it's nice what
ridiculous
you know what they were like decrees for
you
all right
if you're not getting ridiculed it means
people don't like you
and many thanks to all the men and women
in the army navy air force marines you
are the ones that carry out the will of
our country
and you are also the ones who pay the
price and we are forever indebted to you
for your sacrifice
and to police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
you step up and you protect us here on
the home front and we are indebted to
your service as well
and everyone else out there
this might seem obvious
but think about what you're doing
weigh the risks and the benefits
the strategic benefits
the reward
and the consequences
and make sure
make sure that you are doing the right
things
for the right reasons
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko